♪ ♪
>> THE GAME AWARDS WILL BEGIN AT
THE TOP OF THE HOUR FEATURING
MUSICAL PERFORMANCES BY
GREEN DAY, GRIMES, AND CHVRCHES
AND BRANDO LOOKS AT GEARS
TACTICS BUT WHILE THE THEATER
FILLS IN BEHIND ME AND THE WORLD
GETS THEIR POPCORN READY, WE'VE
GOT 30 MINUTES OF AWARDS,
SPECIAL GUESTS AND WORLD
PREMIERES OF OUR OWN IN THE
PRESHOW, INCLUDING A BRAND-NEW
TRAILER FOR "FINAL FANTASY SEVEN
REMAKE" THERE IS NO BETTER WAY
TO KICK OFF THEN BY HANDING OUT
OUR FIRST TROPHY OF THE NIGHT,
THE GAME AWARDS HAVE A NEW
CATEGORY TO HONOR THE TEAMS TO
UNDER THE COMMUNITY, THE BEST
COMMUNITY SUPPORT AWARD GOES TO
A GAME THAT LISTENS, REACTS AND
RESPONDS WITH RESPECT AND
TRANSPARENCY.
THE NOMINEES FOR BEST COMMUNITY
SUPPORT ARE "APEX LEGENDS."
"DESTINY 2".
"FINAL FANTASY XIV."
"FORTNITE."
AND RAINBOW SIX SIEGE.
IN THE WI WINNER IS "DESTINY 2".
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THIS IS
AN HONOR.
I'VE GOT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PEOPLE AT THE BUNGEE WHO HAVE
WORKED SO HARD TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY STARTING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY TEAM HORROR ON THE
FRONT LINES EVERY DAY
INTERACTING WITH OUR FANS, THE
CORE DEVELOPMENT TEAM, OUR
OPERATIONS FOLKS, EVERYONE CARES
SO MUCH ABOUT THIS GAME AND I'VE
GOT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THEIR
HARD WORK.
>> SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR FANS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
HUGE CONGRATULATIONS TO
"DESTINY 2" FOR WINNING OUR
FIRST TO MY FIRST EVER COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AWARD.
THE GAME AWARDS AS A SHOW ABOUT
CELEBRATING ALL OF GAMING, MORE
THAN JUST THE WINNERS.
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT YOU WILL
SEE UNEXPECTED ADDITIONS TO
GAMES YOU LOVE, CHECK-IN'S ON
GAMES YOU ARE ANTICIPATING AND
REVEALS WHO NEVER SAW COMING.
HERE IS THE FIRST OF MANY WORLD
PREMIERES.
>> I CAN SENSE A GREAT COSMIC
DISTURBANCE, WE MUST BE PREPARED
FOR THE WORST.
>> TIME TO CHANGE HISTORY FOR
THE BETTER.
>> SOMEONE'S GOT TO BE THE
COOLEST GUY IN THE ROOM.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE FUN, JUST
YOU WAIT.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHO
YOU'RE UP AGAINST?
♪ ♪
>> WELCOME TO THE DANGER ROOM, I
HOPE YOU SURVIVE THE EXPERIENCE.
THE PHOENIX FORCE HAS
REAWAKENED.
>> I WILL CLEANSE THIS WORLD
WITH MY FLAMES!
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> IN 2018, THE GAME AWARDS
TEAMED UP TO HONOR LOCAL
CITIZENS, PEOPLE WHO USE THE
POWER OF GAMES TO CREATE A
POSITIVE NFLUENCE.
TONIGHT I'M JOINED BY ONE OF THE
GLOBAL CITIZENS WE SHOWED LAST
YEAR WHO HAS A NEW PROJECT TO
SHOW A SPIRIT PLEASE WELCOME LOU
!>>SOMEONE FROM AFRICA AND A
REFUGEE, I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO HAS SUPPORTED ME
TO COME UP, FACEBOOK GAMING HAS
BEEN WORKING ON A GAME THAT PUT
A PLAYER IN THE TRUTH OF A
REFUGEE, IT TALKS ABOUT JOURNEY
AND HELPING PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
EMPATHY.
THIS IS SOMETHING, WE CAN BE
ABLE TO CHANGE THE WORLD AND HOW
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD AND SEE
WHAT THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
PLAYING A VIDEO GAME.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE PROJECT.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CREATED "SALAAM" BECAUSE
GAMES ARE A VERY POWERFUL TOOL
TO CREATE EMPATHY AND TO HELP
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND A JOURNEY OF A
REFUGEE.
GROWING UP IN A REFUGEE CAMP, MY
MOTHER SPENT THREE YEARS LOOKING
FOR $300 TO BUY A COMPUTER.
THEN I TAUGHT MYSELF HOW TO
CREATE A VIDEO GAME.
MY MISSION IN CREATING "SALAAM"
IS TO LET THE WORLD KNOW WHAT IT
IS LIKE TO BE A REFUGEE.
WHEN YOU BUY MEDICINE AND FOOD
IN THE GAME, IT GOES TO REAL
REFUGEES.
REFUGEES LIKE ME.
TOGETHER, WE CAN TAKE SMALL
STEPS TO MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> IT'S SO GREAT TO SHOW YOU
GAMES LIKE THIS ONE, WE HAVE
SUCH A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHINE OUR SPOTLIGHT ON GAMES BIG
AND SMALL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING SOME
INTERESTING IN THESE LATER
TONIGHT.
THIS NEXT AWARDS CATEGORY
REPRESENTS DIVERSITY, CLEARLY
DIFFERENT BUDGETS,
NATIONALITIES, AND GENRES, THEY
ALL SHARE ONE THING, EXCELLENT
MUSIC.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
SCORE.
"CADENCE OF HYRULE."
"DEATH STRANDING."
DEDEVIL MAY CRY FIVE.
KINGDOM HEARTS THREE.
AND "SAYONARA WILD HEARTS."
AND THE WINNER IS...
"DEATH STRANDING."
>> WHAT IS GOING ON EMMA I LIKE
YOUR COLORS.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I'VE BEEN NERVOUS THIS WHOLE
WEEK AND I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW, I JUST WANT
TO SAY BIG THANKS AND SHOUT OUT
AND ALSO A CONGRATULATIONS TO
CHVRCHES AND SILENT POETS FOR
HELPING US MAKE THIS SOUNDTRACK
IS VERSATILE AND IS ENDED UP
BEING.
I'M SUPER THANKFUL FOR ALL OF
THE FANS WHO INSPIRED US TO DO
SOMETHING SUPER WEIRD AND I HOPE
WE CAN KEEP ON DOING WEIRD SHIT
GOING FORWARD.
>> THERE'S BEEN ONE GAME
FEATURED IN THE PC GAMING SHOW
THAT CONTINUES TO FILL OUR
IMAGINATION WITH ENDLESS
POSSIBILITIES, I'M TALKING ABOUT
MAN-EATER, THE GAME WHERE YOU
ARE A KILLER SHARK THAT EATS
PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE HUNGRY FOR MORE
MAN-EATER, HERE'S A NEW WORLD
PREMIER.
>> HUMANS KILL 100 MILLION
SHARKS EVERY YEAR.
BUT ONLY FIVE HUMANS ARE KILLED
BY SHARKS.
IT'S TIME TO EVEN THE SCORE.
♪ ♪
[SKRIMMING]
>> EAT, EXPLORE, EVOLVE.
>> NOT EVERYBODY IS MADE TO BE A
FISHERMAN.
>> IT'S SHARK VERSUS MAN.
MAN-EATER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> STEPH CURRY WILL BE HERE
TONIGHT TO AWARDS THE BEST
ESPORTS PLAYER OF 2019 BUT FOR
NOW I HAVE THE HONOR OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THE WINTER FOR
SOME ESPORTS CATEGORIES.
FOR BEST ESPORTS COACH, THE
NOMINEES ARE ADRIAN, KAYN, AND
AND THE WINNER IS...
ZONIC.
FOR BEST ESPORTS EVENT, THE
NOMINEES ARE THE 2019 OVERWATCH
LEAGUE GRAND FINALS.
EVO 2019.
"FORTNITE" WORLD CUP.
I AM 2019.
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP 2019 AND THE
INTERNATIONAL 2019.
AND THE WINNER IS
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP 2019.
FOR BEST ESPORTS HOST, THE
NOMINEES ARE REDEYE, MACHINE,
GOLDEN BOY AND CANDACE.
AND THE WINNER IS SJOKZ.
AND FOR BEST ESPORTS TEEN THE
NOMINEES ARE ASTRALIS, G2, OG,
SAN FRANCISCO SHOCK, AND TEAM
LIQUID.
AND THE WINNER IS G2 ESPORTS.
HUGE CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF
THE WINNERS, NOW WE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY HIGH AND
WHAT'S UP TO EVERYONE WATCHING
THE GAME AWARDS LIVE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO TAKE A SHORT
BREAK BUT FIRST HERE'S A LITTLE
MESSAGE FROM A COUPLE OF THE
STARS OF JUMANJI NEXT LEVEL.
>> WE CHECKED OUT DREAMS AND GOT
TO SEE THE PLAYSTATION VERSIONS
OF OURSELVES, IT WAS TRIPPY.
WE ARE IN A GAME.
ESPECIALLY YOUR FACE IT WAS SO
HANDSOME.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT ME, I'M BACK.
>> YOU CAN BE THE JUDGE WHEN YOU
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
>> WE CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU TO SEE
JUMANJI THE NEXT LEVEL.
ARE IN A VIDEO GAME.
♪ ♪
>> NOMINATED FOR 2019 GAMING
TWEETS OF THE YEAR.
WHO'S IT GOING TO BE?
'S DAY TWO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE GAME
AWARDS" PRESHOW.
THIS SUMMER I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF JOINING GEOFF KEIGHLEY TO
COHOST GAMES, OPENING NIGHT
LIVE, ONE OF THE GAMES WE
PREVIEWED WAS AMPLITUDE STUDIOS
HUMANKIND, HERE TO UNVEIL A NEW
GAMEPLAY FEATURE IN THE FIRST
TRAILER WITH GAMEPLAY, PLEASE
WELCOME JEFF SPOCK.
>> I'M VERY EXCITED AND KIND OF
TERRIFIED TO BE HERE.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER A QUESTION
I'VE BEEN HEARING CONSTANTLY
SINCE WE ANNOUNCED THE GAME THIS
SUMMER, THE QUESTION IS WHO IN
MY PLAN?
A KING, QUEEN, HISTORICAL
FIGURE, LEADER OF THE
CIVILIZATION.
IF YOU ARE PLAYING YOU, YOU
CREATE A HIGHLY CUSTOMIZABLE
AVATAR THAT WILL EVOLVE VISUALLY
AS YOU PLAY THE GAME AS YOU MAKE
GAMEPLAY DECISIONS, AS YOU WIN
ACHIEVEMENTS, AS YOU SELECT
CULTURES, YOU WILL SEE THAT
EVOLVE ON THE AVATAR ITSELF
WHICH MEANS AT THE END OF THE
GAME YOU WILL HAVE A RECORD AND
A TROPHY OF HOW YOU CHANGED
HUMANKIND.
WE HAVE TONS OF IDEAS OF WHERE
THE AVATAR SYSTEM CAN GO, WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT IT BUT IF I TALK
ABOUT THEM, THE PROGRAMMERS WILL
DISEMBOWEL ME WHEN I GET HOME SO
IN ORDER TO AVOID THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER A TRAILER.
WE HAVE A WORLD PREMIER GAME
EXPERIENCE AND GAMEPLAY TRAILER
TO SHOWCASE THE "HUMANKIND"
AVATAR SYSTEM.
>> WHY DON'T WE TAKE A LOOK?
♪ ♪
>> IT ALL STARTED WAY BACK, BACK
TO BASICS.
THE GOOD OLD DAYS.
GATHERING, HUNTING, BACK TO
GATHERING.
WE SWITCHED FROM A COLD TO A
COOL PLACE TO SIT AND I FOUND
THE PERFECT SPOT FOR MY PEOPLE.
AT FIRST IT WAS JUST A FEW WALLS
TO KEEP THE BEARS OUT AND THE
PIGS IN BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT IS.
ONE DISTRICT LED TO ANOTHER AND
IT KIND OF SNOWBALLED.
THE PROBLEM WAS THE NEIGHBORS
THOUGHT THE GRASS WAS GREENER ON
MY SIDE OF THE FENCE BUT WE SAW
THEM COMING FROM A MILE AWAY.
ALL I HAD TO DO WAS GIVE THE
ORDER.
THEIR FIRST MISTAKE, BRINGING
INFANTRY TO A CAVALRY FIGHT.
NEXT, LOSING THE HIGH GROUND.
FINAL MISTAKE, NOT KEEPING UP IN
THE ARMS RACE.
EVENTUALLY PEACE PREVAILED AND
WE CAME TO AN UNDERSTANDING.
THEY SURRENDERED AND I LET THEM
LIVE.
TURNS OUT, WE HAD A LOT TO LEARN
FROM THEM AND TOGETHER WE BECAME
MORE THAN THE SUM OF OUR PARTS,
A UNIQUE MIX OF CULTURES AND
BELIEFS.
I WOULD SAY I LEFT MY MARK ON
HUMANKIND AND I'M JUST GETTING
STARTED.
THAT'S JUST MY STORY.
>> TELL ME, WHAT WILL YOURS BE?
♪ ♪
>> FOR OUR NEXT WORLD PREMIER,
THIS IS TOTALLY TRUE I'M NOT
LYING TO YOU, THEY HAVEN'T TOLD
ME WHAT IT IS YET.
I AM JUST AS IN THE DARK AS ALL
OF YOU NOW, AND I'VE GOT TO SAY
IT'S PRETTY EXCITING.
I HAVE NO CLUE WHAT TO EXPECT
BUT WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER,
SO LET'S KICK BACK AND ENJOY
THIS ONE.
♪ ♪
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> BEST FRIENDS FOREVER.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS IS GOODBYE.
>> IN 20 YEARS, I WILL RETURN.
>> IS THAT YOU?
>> DAMON, I LOVE YOU!
>> DO IT.
APPARENTLY SUPERHEROES ARE
POPULAR IN THIS COUNTRY SO WE
ARE GOING TO JUMP ON THAT!
>> WHAT ARE YOU?
>> I'M A GOD DAMN SUPERHERO.
>> SUPERHERO?
YOU MUST MEAN ME.
THE LACTIC SUPERHERO RANKINGS,
WHAT?
THERE IS AN EXTENDED VERSION.
2020 RELEASE, GOOD LUCK!
>> RIGHT NOW, WE ARE STREAMING
ALL OVER THE PLANET ON OVER 50
DIFFERENT PLATFORMS, THROUGHOUT
THE NIGHT WILL BE RUNNING POLES
FOR TWITCH AUDIENCE TO PREDICT
CATEGORIES LIKE ESPORTS PLAYER
AND ONGOING GAME, STAY TUNED FOR
THEM.
IF YOU ARE ON TIKTOK YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN WE WILL CELEBRATE
GAMING PAST WEEK WITH A SPECIAL
GAMING ON TIKTOK CHALLENGE.
USE THE HASHTAG TO SHOW US HOW
YOU ARE CELEBRATING VIDEO GAME'S
BIGGEST NIGHT.
LASTLY WE ARE SHOUTING OUT THE
MOST ACTIVE GAME COMMUNITIES ON
REDDIT IN 2019.
"FORTNITE," "LEAGUE OF LEGENDS,"
AND DESTINY BUT NOW I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR ANOTHER WORLD PREMIER.
HERE IS A BRAND-NEW TRAILER FOR
ONE OF NEXT YEAR'S MOST
ANTICIPATED GAMES, FINAL FANTASY
SEVEN REMAKE.
>> I'M INVOLVED IN THINGS,
DANGEROUS THINGS.
>> SO?
>> SO KEEP YOUR DISTANCE.
>> WHAT WAS HIS NAME AGAIN?
>> CLOUD, CLOUD STRIFE.
THIS IS A ONE TIME GATE, WHEN
IT'S DONE, WE ARE DONE.
>> NOBODY DOES SOMETHING THIS
CRAZY JUST FOR MONEY.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO STAND THERE
AND PRETEND YOU CAN'T HEAR THE
PLAINTIFF CRYING OUT IN PAIN?
I KNOW YOU CAN!
>> I WOULD WORRY LESS ABOUT THE
PLANET AND WORRY MORE ABOUT THE
NEXT FIVE SECONDS.
♪ ♪
>> OKAY THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
>> YOU WEREN'T THINKING OF
LEAVING ANYTIME SOON, WHERE YOU?
>> IT SEEMS THIS OLD FRIEND OF
MINE IS IN A TIGHT SPOT.
A LONG TIME AGO I MADE A
PROMISE.
>> I'M REALLY GLAD TO HAVE YOU
BACK.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> BEFORE I HAND THE SHOW OVER
TO GEOFF KEIGHLEY I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF PRESENTING ONE MORE
GAME AWARD IN OUR PRESHOW, HERE
ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
FIGHTING GAME.
"DEAD OR ALIVE 6".
"JUMP FORCE."
"MORTAL KOMBAT 11".
"SAMURAI SHOWDOWN."
AND "SUPER SMASH BROS. ULTI
ULTIMATE."
AND THE WINNER IS "SUPER SMASH
BROS. ULTIMATE."
>> THANK YOU GAME AWARDS, "SUPER
SMASH BROS. ULTIMATE" IS MORE
THAN JUST A FIGHTING GAME.
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE THAT BRINGS
PEOPLE TOGETHER, IT'S A SHOWCASE
FOR SOME OF THE MOST FAMOUS
CHARACTERS, MUSIC, GAME WORLDS
IN VIDEO GAME HISTORY AND THE
FACT THAT ALL OF THIS COMES
TOGETHER SO SEAMLESSLY AND
BEAUTIFULLY IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE DEDICATION, THE HARD WORK
AND THE SKILL OF THE DEVELOPMENT
TEAM.
THIS AWARD IS FOR THEM,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
-  AS YOU CAN SEE, WE ARE NOW
SECONDS AWAY FROM THE START OF
THE FAKE SHOW, HOW EXCITED IS
EVERYBODY?
THE GAME AWARDS ORCHESTRA IS
REPAIRED, GEOFF KEIGHLEY IS
BUTTONING UP HIS TUX AND
EVERYONE HERE IN THE LIVE
AUDIENCE SEEMS READY TO GO.
LET'S HEAR IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE SUCH A SPECIAL
SHOW.
GREEN DAY, CHVRCHES, AND GRIMES
WILL ALL BE PERFORMING, A BUNCH
OF WORLD PREMIERES THAT ARE ARE
GOING TO AMAZE EVERYONE AND I
HONESTLY HAVE NO IDEA WHO'S
GOING TO WIN GAME OF THE YEAR.
THAT'S A WRAP ON OUR PRESHOW,
I'M SYDNEE GOODMAN.
HAVE FUN AND ENJOY THE SHOW,
"THE GAME AWARDS" STARTS RIGHT
NOW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
♪ WHEN WE'VE STOPPED LOOKING
UP?
♪
♪ YOU CAN TAKE MY HEART ♪
♪ AND HOLD IT TOGETHER AS WE ♪
♪ FALL APART ♪
♪ MAY BE TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE A
MARK ♪
♪ IN THE STARS, WE EMBARK ♪
♪ AND KEEP US TOGETHER AS THE
LIGHTS GO DARK ♪
♪ LET'S TELL THE TRUTH JUST FOR
ONCE ♪
♪ ASKING FOR AN ANSWER ♪
♪ NOW THAT IT'S ALL SAID AND
DONE ♪
♪ NOTHING REALLY MATTERS ♪
♪ WHAT WILL BECOME OF US ALL ♪
♪ IF WE DARE TO DREAM AT THE
END ♪
♪ OF THE SCENE?
♪
♪ YOU CAN TAKE MY HEART ♪
♪ AND HOLD IT TOGETHER AS WE
FALL APART ♪
♪ MAY BE TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE A
MARK IN THE STARS ♪
♪ WE EMBARK AND KEEP US TOGETHER
AS THE LIGHTS GO DARK ♪
♪ YOU CAN TAKE MY HEART ♪
♪ AND HOLD IT TOGETHER AS WE
FALL APART ♪
♪ MAY BE TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE A
MARK ♪
♪ IN THE STARS WE EMBARK ♪
♪ AND KEEP US TOGETHER AS THE
LIGHTS GO DARK ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪
- WE CALL THE HOME.
- IT'S NOT THE WEAPONS I DON'T
TRUST, IT'S THE PEOPLE THAT USE
THEM.
- TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
- I NEED TO FIX THIS.
- THEY CAN BE BEAUTIFUL OR
TERRIBLE WE ARE ALL TRANSFIXED.
- WE ARE WAITING FOR YOU.
- YOU ARE UNFIT TO WEAR THIS
CROWN!
- KILL EVERY LAST ONE OF THEM!
- I'LL KEEP HER REAL SAFE.
- WE NEED YOUR HELP.
- NOW, PLEASE WELCOME YOUR HOST
AND THE CREATOR OF "THE GAME
AWARDS," GEOFF KEIGHLEY.
- WELCOME TO "THE GAME AWARDS"
2019, ARE YOU GUYS READY TO
CELEBRATE VIDEO GAMES TONIGHT?
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS THE
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE SHOW,
WE HAVE SO MANY AMAZING SPECIAL
GUEST, MR. KOJIMA, REGGIE,
MR. MIYAZAKI, FIRST OF ALL LET'S
GIVE IT UP AGAIN FOR CHVRCHES
AND "THE GAME AWARDS" ORCHESTRA,
WASN'T THAT BEAUTIFUL?
TONIGHT, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
AMAZES ME ABOUT THIS SHOW IS HOW
WE CONNECT THE WORLD AROUND
GAMES, WE ARE LIVE ON OVER 50
PLATFORMS AROUND THE WORLD.
I WANT TO SAY TO EVERYONE
WATCHING AROUND THE WORLD, IF
YOU ARE IN EUROPE I KNOW IT'S
LATE AT NIGHT -- I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE IT WORTH YOUR
WHILE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF COOL SURPRISES
TONIGHT.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER TO CELEBRATE
VIDEO GAMES.
OUR SHOW TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE AWARDS AND A LOT OF
BRAND-NEW GAME ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
SURPRISES FOR YOU, STAY TUNED
FOR THAT.
WE KNOW YOU LIKE THOSE AND WE
ALSO HAVE PERFORMANCES BY
GREEN DAY [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND GRIMES, STAY TUNED.
TO KICK THINGS OFF LET'S GET TO
OUR FIRST AWARD AND BRING IN OUR
FIRST PRESENTER.
HE IS A SCREEN WRITER AND
PRODUCER KNOWN FOR THE DARK
KNIGHT AND THE COCREATOR OF
WESTWORLD, PLEASE WELCOME
JONATHAN NOLAN.
♪ ♪
- I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE AWARD
FOR BEST NARRATIVE.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT NARRATIVE ON
WESTWORLD WHERE CHARACTERS
CHEWINCHOOSE THEIR OWN PATH, ANA
WE INVENTED ALL OUR SELVES,
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WHEN SOMEONE ASKS WHAT IS BEST
STORY TELLING, IT'S NOT MOVIES
OR A SHOW, IT'S GAMES.
GAMES LIKE FALLOUT, BIO SHOCK,
HALF-LIFE, RED DEAD REDEMPTION.
ALL HUGELY INFLUENTIAL.
YOU CAN SEE THE ECHOES OF THOSE
GAMES IN OUR SHOW.
EVAN RACHEL WOOD'S CHARACTER
DOLORES HAS MORE THAN A LITTLE
BIT IN COMMON WITH ELIZABETH,
JAMES MARTINSON'S CHARACTER
TEDDY WAS BASED ON HIS CHARACTER
IN SONIC THE HEDGEHOG.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I FAILED TO
MENTION THE DEBT OF HONOR THAT
ED HARRIS CHARACTER OWES TO
KUBRICK.
Q-BERT.
>> BEST NARRATIVE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT A DREAM I HAD LAST NIGHT.
>> THERE IS A DEAD BODY.
- HUNGRY FOR ADVENTURE?
OUR COLONY HAS A PLACE FOR
EVERYONE?
>> AND THE WINNER IS...
"DISCO ELYSIUM."
- "DISCO ELYSIUM" WINS THE BEST
GAME AWARD FOR BEST ROLE-PLAYING
GAME.
- IT'S ABSOLUTELY SURREAL TO BE
HERE.
HONESTLY IT MAKES ME REALLY
SPEECHLESS BUT I DEFINITELY WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO BELIEVED
THIS GAME EXISTS WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED TALKING ABOUT IT AND I
WANT TO THANK THE INDUSTRY FOR
WELCOMING US, IT'S BEEN
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
OF COURSE I WANT TO THANK OUR
FANS WHO REALLY PROVED THAT
THESE KINDS OF NARRATIVE GAMES
HAVE THEIR SPACE IN THIS
INDUSTRY.
THANKS A LOT.
♪ ♪
- CONGRATULATIONS, WE HAVE SUCH
A BIG SHOW AHEAD.
I WANT TO MENTION RIGHT NOW ON
TWITCH WE HAVE OVER 900,000
CONCURRENT VIEWERS WATCHING THE
THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU GUYS ARE
EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE GOING
ON AND HE FANS ON TWITCH ARE
PREDICTING WHO WILL TAKE HOME
THE GAME AWARDS TONIGHT.
WE HAVE A POLL OPEN, WHO DOES
THE AUDIENCE THINK IS GOING TO
WIN THE BEST ESPORTS PLAYER
AWARD?
YOU CAN VOTE AND WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT YOUR PREDICTIONS.
WE'VE GOT MORE AWARDS, GREAT
MUSIC, AND OF COURSE GAME
PREMIERES.
WORLD PREMIER'S ARE A BIG PART
OF THIS SHOW AND YOU GUYS HAVE A
LOT OF EXPECTATIONS ON THE
INTERNET FOR THINGS, LOTS OF
RUMORS AND LOTS OF LEAKS AND
SOMETIMES THERE ARE SURPRISES
THAT COME OUT OF NOWHERE.
♪ ♪
- LET'S SUPPOSE YOU WERE ABLE
ANY NIGHT TO DREAM ANY DREAM YOU
WANTED TO DREAM.
AND THAT YOU COULD HAVE THE
POWER WITHIN ONE NIGHT TO DREAM
75 YEARS OF TIME.
AND YOU WOULD NATURALLY AS YOU
BEGAN ON THIS ADVENTURE OF
DREAMS FILL ALL YOUR WISHES, BUT
NOW LET'S HAVE A SURPRISE.
LET'S HAVE A DREAM THAT ISN'T
UNDER CONTROL.
AND THEN YOU WOULD GET MORE AND
MORE ADVENTUROUS.
AND YOU WOULD MAKE FURTHER AND
FURTHER GAMBLES AS TO WHAT YOU
WOULD DREAM.
AND FINALLY YOU WOULD DREAM
WHERE YOU ARE NOW.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Announcer: AND NOW, HE'S
THE HEAD OF XBOX, PLEASE WELCOME
PHIL SPENCER.
- FOR 18 YEARS AND THREE
GENERATIONS, WE'VE DESIGNED XBOX
CONSOLES TO POWER YOUR DREAMS,
WE SEE A FUTURE WHERE YOU ARE
INSTANTLY IN YOUR GAMES OR
WORLDS OR EVEN MORE LIFELIKE
IMMERSIVE, RESPONSIVE, AND
SURPRISING.
WHERE YOU ARE AT THE CENTER OF
YOUR GAMING EXPERIENCE.
NEXT HOLIDAY, XBOX SERIES ACTS
WILL LEAD US INTO THE FUTURE OF
CONSOLE GAMING, OUR FASTEST,
MOST POWERFUL XBOX WILL SET A
NEW BAR FOR PERFORMANCE, SPEED,
COMPATIBILITY, DEVELOPERS AROUND
THE GLOBE ARE ALREADY HARD AT
WORK BUILDING GAMES FOR XBOX
SERIES X.
OUR 15 XBOX GAME STUDIOS ARE
DEVELOPING THE LARGEST AND MOST
CREATIVELY DIVERSE LINEUP OF
EXCLUSIVE GAMES IN OUR HISTORY.
TONIGHT I'M PROUD TO REVEAL A
PROJECT EARLY IN DEVELOPMENT
FROM INCREDIBLY TALENTED AND
CREATIVE TEAM WHO ARE NO
STRANGERS TO THE GAME AWARDS.
WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE WAS ALL
CAPTURED AS BEING BUILT TO TAKE
FULL ADVANTAGE OF XBOX SERIES X.
♪ ♪
[CHANTING]
- THE FUND IS JUST BEGINNING, WE
GOT OTHER GREAT SURPRISES COMING
UP AT "THE GAME AWARDS."
WE JUST RAN A POLL TO SEE WHO
YOU THINK IS GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS THE BEST ESPORTS
PLAYER AND THE RESULTS ARE --
THE TWITCH COMMUNITY PICKED
FAKIR.
THAT AWARD IS COMING UP NEXT AND
NBA SUPERSTAR IS HEADED HERE,
AND WE GOT PERFORMANCES BY
GREEN DAY AND GRIMES, MORE
AMAZING MUSIC, SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS," "FORTNITE,"
AND "APEX LEGENDS."
NORMAN REEDUS IS HERE, REGGIE IS
IN THE HOUSE, WE'VE GOT A LOT
MORE SURPRISES.
LAST YEAR WE STARTED A NEW
INITIATIVE WITH FACEBOOK TO
SPOTLIGHT UNIQUE STORIES WITH
THE GAMING COMMUNITY AROUND THE
WORLD, WE GOT THREE NEW AMAZING
STORIES ABOUT A GLOBAL GAMING
CITIZENS.
I'M SO PROUD TO HAVE THESE IN
THE SHOW, I CAN'T WAIT TO SHOW
YOU TONIGHT.
HERE'S OUR FIRST GLOBAL GAMING
CITIZEN FOR 2019.
- I WAS BORN AN AFRICAN REFUGEE
GROWING UP WITH THE FEAR OF MY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
OR NOT -- I'M NOT ABLE TO GO
BACK TO MY COUNTRY.
AFGHANISTAN IS A TRADITIONAL
COUNTRY, THERE'S A HUGE PROBLEM
HERE FOR WOMEN ACCESSING
EDUCATION SO I DECIDED ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH SO I THOUGHT ABOUT
CODING, CODED TO INSPIRE IS THE
FIRST CODING SCHOOL FOR GIRLS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
OUR STUDENTS TOLD ME THEY WERE
TIRED OF PLAYING GAMES WHERE THE
MEN ARE SUPERHEROES, IT'S ALWAYS
PRETTY WHITE MEN AND I'M LIKE
WHY DON'T YOU CREATE YOUR OWN
GAME?
AFGHAN HERO GIRLS.
WHEN THEY SEE THE GAME THEY ARE
PLAYING, THAT'S EMPOWERMENT IN
ITSELF.
THEY UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A
VOICE AND THEY SHOULD BE HEARD.
- IS IT POSSIBLE THE PAST AND
FUTURE ARE COLLIDING?
♪ ♪
[MORTAL KOMBAT THEME]
- LET THE NEW ERA BEGAN.
[LAUGHTER]
- HOLD.
WELL AREN'T YOU JUST AS CUTE AS
A BUTTON.
- ARE YOU JUST AS CREEPY AS
[BLEEP].
- FLATTERY WILL GET YOU NOWHERE,
DEAR.
- RATED M FOR MATURE.
♪ ♪
[BABY CRYING]
- PLAYSTATION.
- NINTENDO SWITCH HAS GAMES,
LOTS OF GAMES TO PLAY ANYTIME,
ANYWHERE.
♪ ♪
- FIND THE GAMES YOU WANT TO
PLAY YOUR WAY ON T NINTENDO SWIH
AND NINTENDO SWITCH LIGHT.
♪ ♪
- NOW PLEASE WELCOME THREE-TIME
NBA CHAMPION AND TWO-TIME MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER, FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS, IT'S
STEPHEN CURRY.
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW, I HAD
MY OWN GAMING RELATED INJURY
RECENTLY.
I WENT FOR THAT TRIANGLE BUTTON
AND NEXT THING YOU KNOW I'M ON
THE FLOOR.
2K IS NO JOKE.
ONCE AGAIN, ESPORTS IS THE
FASTEST GROWING SPORT ON THE
PLANET AND IS STILL BREAKING
RECORDS WITH MASSIVE
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR PRIZE POOLS.
THE AWARD FOR BEST ESPORTS
PLAYER RECOGNIZES OUTSTANDING
PLAY REGARDLESS OF THE GAME AND
GOOD SPORTSMANSHIP.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- BEST ESPORTS PLAYER.
- "FORTNITE" WORLD CHAMPION!
- HE TRIES TO JUMP AWAY, SMASHES
FORWARD.
- THAT'S WHAT WE LIKE!
- AND THE GAME AWARD FOR BEST
ESPORTS PLAYER GOES TO BUGHA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
- THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
THIS IS THE BEST NIGHT OF THE
YEAR.
THANK YOU ALL TO MY FANS, MY
FAMILY, MY FRIENDS, MY TEAM,
MOST IMPORTANTLY EPIC GAMES FOR
MAKING ANY OF THIS POSSIBLE I'M
SO GLAD TO BE PART OF THIS
COMMUNITY AND I CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE,
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
♪ ♪
- ON YOUR FEET.
- NOT DEAD YET.
- A THOUSAND YEAR WAR JUST THE O
START THE APOCALYPSE.
- BEAUTIFUL, DEADLY IN OUR WAY.
- NO STORM CAN STOP US.
- PLAYSTATION.
- YOU NOTICED THAT?
PLAYSTATION FIVE, THIS SHOW IS
ON FIRE.
I'M HERE WITH KEITH LEE THE CEO
OF COUNTERPLAY AND THE PRESIDENT
OF GEARBOX PUBLISHING, BRAND-NEW
ANNOUNCEMENT, BRAND-NEW IP, NEW
GAME, WHAT IS GOD FALL!
- IT'S A BRAND-NEW IP SET IN A
FANTASY UNIVERSE FILLED WITH
HEROIC KNIGHTS AND MYSTERIOUS
MAGIC, WE CALLED IT A LOOTER
SLASHER.
- HOW IS THIS GOING TO PLAY?
- WE ARE HERE TO REINVENT COMBAT
FOR ACTION RPGs, WILL HAVE
THIRD TIME MELEE COMBAT AS YOU
HUNT FOR AWESOME LOOT.
YOU CAN ALSO PLAY THE GAME AND
SOLO AS WELL AS CO-OP, IT'S
GOING TO BE FUN FOR EVERYONE.
- YOU CAN SEE THE GAME WE ARE
GOING TO GET TO PLAY, GEARBOX
NOMINATED FOR BORDERLANDS
CONGRATS ON THAT BUT HOW DO YOU
FIT IN THIS PICTURE?
- YOU KNOW WE LOVE OUR CO-OP AND
OUR GEARBOX, HERE WE ARE.
WHEN HE SHOWED US GOD FALL IT
WAS SO AMAZING TO US, WE HAD TO
CALL OUR FRIENDS AT SONY AND
EPIC AND SAY HELP US WORK ON
TECHNOLOGY AND HARDWARE, WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR
YOU.
WE ARE SO EXCITED, IT'S GOING TO
BE LAUNCHED EXCLUSIVELY ON THE
PLAYSTATION FIVE AND EPIC GAME
STORE THIS HOLIDAY.
>> HOLIDAY 2020, PLAYSTATION
FIVE GAMES.
CONGRATULATIONS, IT LOOKS
INCREDIBLE AND WE WILL SEE MORE
NEXT YEAR.
WE WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SOME
OTHER WINNERS TONIGHT, BEST IN
GAME AUDIO AND SOUND DESIGN,
THOSE NOMINEES ARE "CALL OF
DUTY: MODERN WARFARE."
CONTROL.
"DEATH STRANDING."
"GEARS 5".
RESIDEIS AN EVIL TWO.
AND "SEKIRO: SHADOWS DIE TWICE."
IN THE GAME AWARD GOES TO "CALL
OF DUTY: MODERN WARFARE."
FOR BEST STRATEGY GAME FOCUSED
ON REAL-TIME OR TURN-BASED
STRATEGY, THOSE NOMINEES ARE
"AGE OF WONDERS: PLANETFALL,"
"ANNO 1800", FIRE EMBLEM FREE
HOUSES, "TOTAL WAR: THREE
KINGDOMS," AND "TROPICO 6" AND
"WARGROOVE."
THE GAME AWARD GOES TO "FIRE
EMBLEM: THREE HOUSES."
IN CONTENT CREATOR OF THE YEAR,
FOR A STREAMER OR CREATOR WHO
MADE AN IMPORTANT IMPACT ON THE
INDUSTRY THIS YEAR, THE NOMINEES
ARE COURAGE, DR. LUPO, EWOK, AND
SHROUD.
IN THE GAME AWARD GOES TO SHROUD
THE, CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'VE HAD SOME GREAT WORLD
PREMIERES TO START OFF THE SHOW,
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT XBOX, WE
TALKED ABOUT PLAYSTATION,
ANOTHER PLATFORM WE HAVE ANOTHER
WORLD PREMIERE GAME ANNOUNCEMENT
I DON'T THINK YOU GUYS ARE
EXPECTING, CHECK THIS OUT.
- IT IS TIME TO CHOOSE, EXCEPT
YOUR FATE AND AWAIT OBLIVION OR
MAKE US STAND AND FIGHT FOR
SURVIVAL.
STEP INTO THE LIGHT YOUNG HERO,
BE BRAVE.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- RIGHT NOW, I'M JOINED BY MY
FELLOW CANADIAN REBECCA FORD,
COMMUNITY DIRECTOR AT DIGITAL
EXTREMES.
WELCOME TO THE GAME AWARDS,
YOU'VE BEEN UP HERE BEFORE.
WAR FRAME, TELL US WHAT'S THE
LATEST ON WAR FRAME?
- WE'VE BEEN MAKING THIS GAME
FOR SEVEN YEARS AND EACH YEAR WE
UPDATED WITH SPACE NINJA AND WE
THINK IT'S TIME TO GO WITH SPACE
PIRATE.
- WHAT CAN YOU TELL US, ONCE IT
GOING TO COME OUT?
- WE ARE THINKING ON PC WE ARE
GOING TO LAUNCH IT RIGHT NOW.
- LIVE RIGHT NOW, THAT'S
FANTASTIC.
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
HANDS ON IT TONIGHT, ANYTHING
ELSE?
>> PLAYSTATION FOUR AND XBOX ONE
HALF THE RISING TIDE UPDATE.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING WAR
FRAME'S STORY, THERE'S A LOT TO
FIND THIS UPDATE SO WHY NOT
LAUNCH IT ON PC?
- IT'S OUT RIGHT NOW ON PC.
- LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- TONIGHT WE ARE HAPPY TO
WELCOME SAMSUNG AS A NEW PARTNER
AND THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT YOU
WILL BE HEARING FROM MY FELLOW
CANADIAN, LOTS OF CANADIANS
TONIGHT, ABOUT SAMSUNG'S TVs
WHICH ARE OPTIMIZED FOR THE BEST
GAMING EXPERIENCE, TAKE A LOOK.
- I'M LINUS AND I WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE WAYS
LIVING ROOM GAMING IS BETTER
THAN EVER.
WHEN I WAS A KID MY FIRST GAMING
TV WAS ABOUT THIS BIG AND IT HAD
A VHS PLAYER BUILT INTO IT, NOT
VERY IMMERSIVE.
WITH A SAMSUNG Q  QLED TV, THE
IMAGE CLARITY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
SAMSUNG'S 10-YEAR BURN IN
GUARANTEE, YOU CAN GAME WITHOUT
WORRY.
- MANY PEOPLE KNOW ME AS EWOK, I
AM D DEATH AND I PLAY "FORTNITE"
I WAS A STREAMER WITH A VERY
SMALL FOLLOWING.
EVERYTHING HAS TAKEN OFF AND
IT'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
I'VE BECOME THE FIRST WOMAN IN
PHASE CLAN.
MY GOAL IS TO SEE MANY MORE
FEMALES PLAYING AND CONSIDERED
AT AN EQUAL LEVEL AND I REALLY
WANT TO SEE THAT EXPLODE IN THE
GAMING WORLD.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE REALLY
NICE.
- EWOK IS HERE WITH US TONIGHT,
WE ARE GLAD TO HAVE HER WITH US.
HERE WITH ME NOW IS DANIEL CATCH
CATCH, THE SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
"MAGIC THE GATHERING."
- I'M EXCITED TO TELL YOU IN
JANUARY, MAGIC WILL BE RETURNING
TO OUR MOST BELOVED WORLDS.
THE LAST TIME WE WENT TO -- WE
SAW OUR HERO BETRAYED BY THE
GODS AND BANISHED TO THE
UNDERWORLD.
NOW OUR HERO IS READY TO DEFY
DEATH AND ESCAPE HER FATE.
I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU A SNEAK
PEEK AT WHAT'S IN STORE FOR HER.
THIS IS THE TRAILER FOR THEROS:
BEYOND DEATH.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- THE NEW GAME ANNOUNCEMENTS
KEEP ROLLING, EVENTUALLY WE WILL
GET TO GAMES YOU ALREADY KNOW
ABOUT, BUT LET'S KEEP GOING WITH
THINGS YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
BEFORE -- HERE'S ANOTHER WORLD
PREMIERE.
[RAIN FALLING]
SPEAK OUT NOW SHE IS THE
CREATIVE DIRECTOR AND LEAD ART
DESIGNER FOR "THE EVIL WITHIN"
SERIES.
, PLEASE WELCOME IKUMI NAKAMURA.
>> GOOD ART CHANGES OVER TIME
BUT GREAT ART STAYS GREAT.
GREAT ART SPARKS OUR BRAINS AND
TELLS US TO CHANGE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN.
SOMETIMES WE NEED TO CHANGE TO
SURVIVE.
THIS YEAR I'VE HAD A BIG CHANGE
IN LIFE AND IT'S A BEEN A CRAZY
YEAR.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
BUT I AM ALIVE.
WAS IT A CRAZY YEAR FOR YOU?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU ARE NOT ALONE.
BECAUSE I AM HERE.
AND WE HAVE GREAT GAMES WITH
GREAT ART.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
ART DIRECTION.
- BEST ART DIRECTION PRESENTED
BY SAMSUNG  QLED.
♪ ♪
- AS YOU KNOW I AM A
FORTUNE-TELLER.
I CAN SEE MIETA.
AND THE WINNER IS "CONTROL."
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
- WOW.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE, I'M TRYING
TO AVOID ANY EXPLICIT LANGUAGE
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE BIG THANK YOU GOES
TO THE ART DIRECTOR, HE'S AN
AMAZING PERSON, HE HAD A
CRYSTAL-CLEAR VISION OF WHAT HE
WANTED TO ACHIEVE WITH CONTROL.
ALSO THE WORLD DESIGN DIRECTOR,
ALL THE CREEPY MONSTERS THAT
EXIST IN THIS GAME.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A BETTER GROUP
OF ARTISTS AND CRATE OF PEOPLE
TO WORK WITH, THIS IS THANKS TO
YOU GUYS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
♪ ♪
- CONGRATULATIONS TO THE GUYS AT
REMEDY, WE HAVE LOTS OF REWARDS
COMING UP.
RIGHT HERE I'M HERE WITH DONALD
MUSTARD, IT'S A YEARLY THING --
YOU GUYS HAVE BUILT QUITE A
FRANCHISE IN "FORTNITE" AND THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE BEEN
SO CRAZY WITH YOU GUYS BUT WHAT
I LOVE IS YOU ARE CONSTANTLY
INNOVATING.
>> I THINK WE ARE ALL JUST
TRYING TO MAKE STUFF AND MAKE IT
FUN, MAKE IT COOL AND YOU NEVER
QUITE EXPECT SOMETHING TO TAKE
OFF THE WAY THAT "FORTNITE" DID.
ONCE THAT MOMENTUM HAPPENED WE
ARE LIKE WE HAVE TO LEAN IN AND
HOW DO WE FIND WAYS TO PUSH THE
IDEA OF WHAT A PERSISTENT
VIRTUAL PLACE CAN BE.
>> START THE YEAR OFF WITH A
CONCERT.
- OVER 10 MILLION PEOPLE IN IT,
WE ROLL INTO HUGE MONSTER FIGHTS
AND THINK WE ARE PLANNING
FOREVER, HOW DO WE FIND A WAY TO
SUCK THE ENTIRE WORLD INTO A
ZERO-POINT BLACK HOLE AND TURN
THE GAME OFF.
>> THAT PALES IN COMPARISON TO
WHAT IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN THIS
WEEKEND.
>YOU GUYS HAVE SEEN TEASING OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT RISKY REELS
TIED TO "STAR WARS."
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT IT?
- I PROBABLY CAN'T TELL YOU
MUCH.
BUT I HAVE A FRIEND WHO CAN.
- HEY EVERYONE IT'S J.J. ABRAMS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE RISE OF
SKYWALKER, JOINED ME IN
"FORTNITE" FOR AN EXCLUSIVE LOOK
AT THE MOVIE.
TO SEE THE WHOLE THING YOU'VE
GOT TO BE IN THE GAME, I WILL
SEE YOU IN "FORTNITE" ON
SATURDAY.
- THIS IS SO COOL, I THINK SOME
PEOPLE THINK YOU'RE JUST RUNNING
A CLIFF AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH YOU WANT TO REVEAL THAT YOU
AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING ALL YEAR
ABOUT BUILDING A LIFE
EXPERIENCE, I'M GOING TO BE IN
THE GAME AS WELL INTERACTING
WITH J.J. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH YOU WANT TO TELL US ABOUT
IT BUT IT'S GOING TO BE A LIFE
PARTICIPATORY EXPERIENCE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE LIVE.
- THAT'S THE GLIDER WE ARE GOING
TO GET.
- THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DO IT LIVE.
- AS YOU DROP OUT OF THE BATTLE
BUS, YOU'RE GOING TO POP THOSE
OUT.
YOU ARE FLYING AROUND AND J.J.
AND JEFF WILL BE THERE LIVE IN
THE GAME AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE
THIS AWESOME CLIP FROM
"STAR WARS," IT'S BRIEF BUT I
HAVE SEEN IT, IF YOU WANT TO SEE
IT AND SOME OTHER CRAZY STUFF IS
GOING TO HAPPEN AND YOU SHOULD
COME.
- I'M EXCITED ABOUT WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR PROGRAMMING INSIDE OF
GAMES, SHARED EXPERIENCES LIKE
THE GAME AWARDS BUT THIS IS
INSIDE THE GAME WORLD, I'M
EXCITED ABOUT WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN ON SATURDAY.
BEFORE THEN I KNOW YOU'VE GOT
SOME COOL THINGS THAT PEOPLE CAN
PICK UP IN "FORTNITE."
- THERE IS ONE MORE THING.
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN GO TO
"FORTNITE" AND THESE ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN THE GAME, THE
AWESOME NEW TROOPER AND THEY ARE
IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW.
GET IT LOADED UP FOR SATURDAY.
- AMAZING, WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE PUT TOGETHER
TO HAVE THIS COME TOGETHER,
THESE THINGS ARE NEVER EASY TO
PULL OFF.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT WHAT IT'S
GOING TO BE.
- SATURDAY, 2:00 P.M. EASTERN
AND IT'S LIVE, WE ARE DOING IT
LIVE AND IT'S GOING TO BE
AMAZING AND CRAZY JUST LIKE
THIS.
- THERE WILL BE OTHER CRAZY
THINGS GOING ON.
THANKS AS ALWAYS FOR COMING BY
"THE GAME AWARDS," I KNOW YOU'RE
HERE FOR A BUNCH OF AWARDS
TONIGHT AS WELL AND WE GOT MUCH
MORE GAME AWARDS COMING UP.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF BRAND-NEW
GAME ANNOUNCEMENTS TONIGHT AND
THIS NEXT ONE COMES FROM A TEAM
AND MY HOME COUNTRY OF CANADA, I
KEEP MENTIONING CANADA.
THIS IS I GAME I SAID WOULD BE A
COOL THING TO ANNOUNCE AT THE
GAME AWARDS, CHECK IT OUT.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- WE GOT COOL STUFF TONIGHT, ONE
OF THE MOST PLAYED GAMES IN THE
WORLD IS "LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" AND
TONIGHT WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE A
RIOT AND ITS NEW DIVISION WITH
US TO REVEAL THE FIRST SINGLE
PLAYER EXPERIENCE FOR THE
FRANCHISE, TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
- MY KING, LONG HAVE YOU WAITED.
NOW THE TIME HAS COME FOR YOUR
REVENGE.
A HARROWING TO CROSS ALL TERROR.
THEY WILL NO FEAR.
SUFFERING.
THEY WILL KNOW YOUR NAME.
- RUINED KING, YOU GUYS HAVE
AMAZING GAMES OVER THE YEARS,
CONGRATULATIONS ON WORKING WITH
A RIOT.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT WE JUST
SAW.
>> I'M EXCITED WE CAN FINALLY
TALK ABOUT THIS I WAS SURE I WAS
GOING TO LEAK IT BEFORE NOW BUT
WE ARE DOING THE FIRST EVER RIOT
FORGE GAME.
AS YOU SAW, IT IS THE RUINED
KING, A "LEAGUE OF LEGENDS"
STORY.
WE ARE BUILDING ON OUR
EXPERIENCE MAKING BATTLE CHASERS
AND DARK CIDERS TO CREATE A
STORY DRIVEN TURN-BASED RPG, WE
HAVE A NEW TAKE ON TURN-BASED
COMBAT THAT'S COOL.
IF THE ART AND VISUALS THAT OUR
STUDIO IS KNOWN FOR END OF THE
TAKES PLACE AFTER BURNING TIDES.
EVERYONE BELIEVES GANGPLANK IS
DEAD, BILGE WATER IS IN CHAOS
AND YOU WILL PLAY AS SOME
CHAMPIONS AND EXPLORE BILGE
WATER, THE SHADOW AISLES AND WE
HAVE OTHER SURPRISES AS WELL.
- THIS IS SOMETHING YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR A LITTLE
WHILE.
- IT'S EXCITING TO HAVE RIOT
WITH US FOR THE FIRST TIME --
- THE GAME IS AMAZING AND IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
- IT MEANS THE WORLD TO US AND I
KNOW ALL OF THE
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" FANS AROUND
THE ENTIRE WORLD ARE TUNED IN
TONIGHT.
- I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR WHAT YOU
GUYS THINK.
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT ANNOUNCEMENT,
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS," FANTASTIC.
- ONE MAY COME BACK, A
PERFORMANCE BY GRIMES, THE AWARD
FOR BEST ACTION GAME WITH NORMAN
REEDUS, AND A SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM AN APEX
LEGEND.
STILL TO COME, BEST MULTIPLAYER
GAME AND AN EXTENDED LOOK AT
GHOSTS OF SOC OF SOJIMA.
- LADIES AND GERMS, THE BIRDS OF
PREY OR HIJACKING THE GAME
AWARDS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
- COME ON!
- WE'VE BEEN HERE TRAINING FOR
WEEKS.
- DON'T TAKE THIS THE WRONG WAY
ARE NOTHING BUT YOU GUYS AREN'T
BIRDS OF PREY MATERIAL, NO
OFFENSE.
- BUT I LOVE YOU.
- OF COURSE YOU DO, NOW QUIT
MESSING AROUND AND GIVE THESE
PEOPLE WHAT THEY WANT.
- IF YOU WANT BOYS TO RESPECT
YOU, YOU HAVE TO SHOW THEM THAT
YOU ARE SERIOUS.
BLOW SOMETHING UP.
HIT SOMEONE.
NOTHING GETS A GUYS ATTENTION
LIKE VIOLENCE.
- I LOVE THIS CHICK, SHE'S GOT
RAGE ISSUES.
- I DON'T HAVE RAGE ISSUES!
♪ ♪
- AGAINST ALL THE EVIL THAT HELL
CAN CONJURE, OR THE WICKEDNESS
THAT MANKIND CAN PRODUCE, WE
WILL STAND UP TO THEM.
ONLY YOU.
- WE HEARD YOU WANTED TO QUIT
VAPING.
- WE CAN BARELY HOLD THESE
PROTEST SIGNS.
- IT'S AN EASY TEXT TO QUIT
SERVICE.
- THE MOST WE CAN DO.
- YOU'LL NEVER SEE HER AGAIN.
- YOU CAN'T KEEP RUNNING
FOREVER.
>> YOU HAVE YET TO SEE JUSTICE.
- BE SURE TO STAY IN THE LIGHT.
- WELCOME BACK TO "THE GAME
AWARDS," MUSIC IS A BIG PART OF
GAMES AND CYBERPUNK 2077 IS ONE
OF THE MOST ANTICIPATED GAMES
COMING OUT NEXT YEAR.
HELLO TO EVERYONE OVER IN POLAND
WORKING HARD TO FINISH THE GAME
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT A
BEHIND-THE-SCENES LOOK AT THE
SOUNDTRACK TO CYBERPUNK 2077,
CHECK IT OUT.
- EVEN IN THE DYSTOPIAN FUTURE,
IT LIVES ON.
- WE WANT THE SOUNDTRACK  --
- IT'S A VERY INTERESTING THING
TO BE PART OF.
- I THINK THE MUSIC FITS WITH
THE CITY BECAUSE THEY ARE SCARY
AND PRETTY AT THE SAME TIME.
- MY MUSIC WILL BE FEATURED IN
CYBERPUNK 2077 AND I'M SUPER
EXCITED.
- IT'S QUITE REBELLIOUS AND IT'S
NOISY AND AGGRESSIVE.
I THINK INDUSTRIAL IS THE WORD.
- I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HOW THE
TWO WORLDS MEET, IT'S BEEN A LOT
OF FUN PLAYING THESE BEATS.
- IT'S VERY PUNK ROCK IN ITS
APPROACH, BUILDING THESE SYSTEMS
AND MAKING ROUGH, EDGY MUSIC.
- PSYCHEDELIC, TRIPPY, ENGAGING.
- YOU CAN SEE A LOT OF
INDUSTRIAL STUFF HAPPENING.
- MIXING AND PUNK MUSIC AND
ELECTRONIC MUSIC.
- WE HAVE SOME TRACKS THAT ARE
DIRTY AND HAPPY AND SOME TRACKS
THAT ARE BEAUTIFUL AND AMBIENT.
- THAT'S A CLUMPS OF WHAT WE
HAVE IN STORE FOR YOU.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- AND NOW HE IS THE STAR OF THE
WALKING DEAD AND A NOMINE FOR
BEST PERFORMANCE FOR HIS ROLE AS
SAM PORTER BRIDGES IN DEBT
STRANDING, HERE IS NORMAN
REEDUS.
- IT'S TIME TO PRESENT THE AWARD
FOR BEST ACTION GAME, THESE
GAMES ARE ALL WILDLY DIFFERENT,
SOME NEW FRANCHISES, SOME%
BELOVED SEQUELS, ALL WITH THEIR
OWN UNIQUE ADVERSARIES AND
OBJECTIVES.
THE ONE THING THEY HAVE IN
COMMON IS THAT THEY SET THE BAR
FOR LIVELY COMBAT AND THRILLS.
READY?
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
- BEST ACTION GAME.
- TRIED TO KEEP UP.
♪ ♪
- TIME TO KICK SOME ASS.
- COVERING FIRE.
>> A ALL RIGHT, THIS IS HEAVY.
AND THE WINNER IS "DEVIL MAY CRY
5".
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
- THANK YOU SO MUCH!
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
THE FANS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTING US AND WAITING 11
YEARS FOR THE SEQUEL.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> I'M REALLY HAPPY TO STICK
WITH MY ROOTS AND TRIED TO MAKE
AS PURE OF AN ACTION GAME AS
POSSIBLE.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>>> DMC IS BACK!
- I'M JOINED BY JEFF ADAM, --
TELL US WHAT YOU'RE WORKING ON.
- I'M EXCITED TO BE HERE FOR THE
WORLD PREMIERE OF THE GAME WE
BEEN WORKING ON IN MONTREAL.
WHEN WE STARTED WORKING ON THIS
GAME, WE HAD THE IDEA TO PUT
ACTION BACK IN ACTION RPG AND
WHAT BETTER PLACE THAN IN
"DUNGEONS & DRAGONS" FORGOTTEN
REALMS.
SLEIGH TOGETHER WITH YOUR
FRIENDS, I'M SUPER PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE ""DUNGEONS & DRAGONS":
DARK ALLIANCE.
"- CHECK IT OUT.
♪ ♪
- UP NEXT IS THE AWARD FOR
THE --
>> IT'S THE MOST WONDERFUL TIME
OF THE YEAR -- A LITTLE PITCHY
ON THAT ONE, I SHOULD KEEP
PRACTICING.
- LOOKS LIKE IT'S A MIRAGE.
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
- WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
GAME AWARDS RIGHT NOW.
- IS THAT TONIGHT, DID I ALREADY
WIN FOR BEST ALL-AROUND
COMPETITOR IN BATTLE ROYALE
BASED ON SKILLS BUT MOSTLY GOOD
LOOKS?
- THAT IS SUCH A SPECIFIC AWARD
AS I TOLD YOU ON TWITTER DOES
NOT EXIST.
- OKAY, I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
KEEPING THE MYSTERY ALIVE FOR
THE AUDIENCE, I GET IT -- IT'S A
SECRET AWARD I GET LATER.
IT'S NOT LIKE I HAVEN'T BEEN
PRACTICING MY ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY MOTHER
MY EXCEPTIONAL GOOD LOOKS.
- WE HAVE A SHOW, LOTS OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO GET TO, IS
THERE A PURPOSE FOR TODAY'S
CALL?
- I KNOW EVERYBODY IS ALWAYS
ASKING FOR MORE CONTENT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY AND I THINK I SPEAK
FOR EVERYONE WHEN I SAY WE'VE
ALL HAD ENOUGH OF CRYPTO.
I'M HERE TO GIVE THE PEOPLE WHAT
THEY WANT.
CHECK THIS OUT, THIS IS SO COOL.
I'M A CAPTAIN!
- THE CAPTAIN OF WHAT?
- THE MIRAGE BO BO VOYAGE.
CAN I PUT YOU DOWN FOR A PLUS
ONE?
- THAT'S THE BEST PART, THIS
PARTY STARTS RIGHT NOW!
♪ ♪
- I'VE GOT PRESENTS FOR EVERYONE
AT THE AWARDS AND ALL OF YOU
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE WATCHING AT
HOME, JOIN ME AT THE PARTY AND
YOU GET THIS FREE EXCLUSIVE
LEGENDARY SKIN OF MY MATCHING G7
AND THE GUN DOESN'T LOOK BAD
EITHER.
- EXTREMELY GENEROUS OF YOU.
- WHAT CAN I SAY, I AM A GIVER.
- WE DO HAVE A SHOW TO GET BACK
TO, THANKS.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE YOU AND
EVERYBODY ELSE AT THE BIGGEST
CELEBRATION IN THE OUTLANDS,
IT'S PARTY TIME.
♪ ♪
- FIRE IN THE HOLE.
- WARM UP IN THE RESPOND
CHAMBER.
- I'M QUICKER THAN YOU THINK.
- I ENJOY THE WINTER MONTHS.
- TIME TO HIBERNATE FOR THE
WINTER.
- YOU KNOW YOU MISSED ME.
- YOU'RE A BIT TOO SLOW.
- LET'S RIDE THE TRAIN - TARGET
SPOTTED.
- WE ARE AWESOME.
- WATSON GET IN HERE WITH ME,
LET'S TAKE AN ELFY.
WHY ARE YOU LOOKING AT ME LET TT
WAY?
- UP NEXT, DR. BUNSEN HONEYDW
AND BEAKER PRESENT GAMES FOR
IMPACT, PLUS REGGIE IS HERE AND
HE IS READY.
LATER, BRAND-NEW LOOK AT "GHOST
OF TSUSHIMA."
, IT'S ALL COMING UP ON "THE
GAME AWARDS."
♪ ♪
- WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE SHOW
COMING UP, WE HAVE A GREEN DAY
COMING UP AND A WORLD PREMIERE
FROM XBOX AND MOON STUDIOS,
HERE'S A BRAND-NEW LOOK.
♪ ♪
- PLANT WITH XBOX GAME PASS.
- MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT BEING
A GAME DESIGNERS I DIDN'T HAVE
TO PICK ONE SUBJECT TO
SPECIALIZE IN, I'M ABLE TO
FOLLOW MY INTERESTS AND SPEND
TIME STUDYING GALACTIC EVOLUTION
OR URBAN PLANNING, WHATEVER IT
IS.
I TURNED THAT INTO A TOY, INTO A
GAME.
PART OF MY JOB IS ENJOYING
EXPLORING THE WORLD AND LETTING
MY INTERESTS TAKE ME WHEREVER I
GO.
- WHEN IT COMES TO UPPING YOUR
COMPETITION LEVEL, THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT MORE FRAMES PER
SECOND MAKES A MEASURABLE
DIFFERENCE, TRUST ME.
THAT'S WHY SAMSUNG'S LATEST QLED
TV FEATURES NATIVE SUPPORT FOR
GAMES RUNNING UP TO 120 FRAMES
PER SECOND WITH VERY LOW INPUT
LAG AND THIS SWEET AUTO GAME
MODE THAT DETECTS WHEN YOU ARE
GAMING AND TURNS OFF ANY EXTRA
IMAGE PROCESSING.
THEY'VE EVEN GOT SMOOTHER
ANIMATIONS WHEN THE FRAME RATE
DIPS.
- THE WAR HAD JUST STARTED WHEN
I ARRIVED TO IRAQ, WE DID OUR
THING, WE HAD EXPERIENCES AND
WHEN WE CAME BACK AND GOT OFF
THAT PLANE, BEFORE WE COULD
EMBRACE OUR LOVED ONES COME OUR
FIRE TEAM LEADER SAYS DO NOT
TELL ANYONE WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU
OR WHAT YOU SAW OR WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED.
THAT STARTS THE STIGMA OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
- STACK UP AS A MILITARY CHARITY
SUPPORTING U.S. AND ALLIED
VETERANS THROUGH GAMING.
OVERWATCH IS OUR NEWEST PROGRAM,
IT'S HAVING A CHAT CLIENT UP,
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO TALK OR IS
INTERESTED IN GETTING INTO
AGAIN, WE HAVE SOMEBODY
AVAILABLE.
- THEY MAY NOT WANT TO COME OUT
HERE AND SEE A COUNSELOR ONCE A
WEEK BUT THEY MAY COME OUT AND
PLAY A VIDEO GAME AND A START
TALKING ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
OF WAR OR THE STRUGGLES THEY ARE
HAVING RIGHT NOW.
IT HAS BECOME MY PASSION TO END
THE STIGMA OF MENTAL HEALTH.
- PLEASE WELCOME TWO OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE VISIONARIES IN THE
HISTORY OF GAMING AND JUST ABOUT
EVERYONE ELSE.
FROM MUPPET LABS, DR. BUNSEN
HONEYDEW AND BEAKER.
- GREETINGS FELLOW GAMING
ENTHUSIAST, I AM DR. BUNSEN
HONEYDEW AND THIS IS MY
ASSISTANT BEAKER.
WHERE DID YOU GO?
I GUESS HE'S STUCK IN THE LOBBY.
[LAUGHTER]
NOTHING?
OH, WELL.
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS, WE WILL
REVEAL THE WINNER OF GAMES FOR
IMPACT BUT FIRST I WAS HOPING --
HERE HE IS NOW!
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I FORGOT WE HAVE A BASEMENT.
VR GOGGLES TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
BRAND-NEW GAME.
[BEEPING]
- HE'S WEARING SUPERGLUE AND
GOGGLES, YOU CAN PUT THEM ON BUT
YOU CAN'T GET THEM OFF.
[SCREAMING]
AND NOW WE WILL PREMIERE THE
EXCITING NEW MUPPET LABS GAME --
I FORGOT, WANT TO BE CALLING AT?
[BEEPING]
- OF COURSE, THE UNTITLED BEAKER
GAME.
EXCELLENT CHOICE, LET THE GAMES
BEGIN.
[BEEPING]
♪ ♪
[SCREAMING]
- HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR
RECOGNIZING PROGRESSIVE GAMES IN
INDUSTRY.
- GAMES FOR IMPACT.
- YOU WANT ME TO PAINT THIS
WHOLE TOWN.
♪ ♪
- WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR YOUR BROTHER.
- WHY IS IT SO DARK?
- HERE WE GO.
AND THE WINNER IS -- WHAT ARE
YOU DOING OUTSIDE THE GAME?
GIVE THAT BACK TO ME, BEAKER GET
HIM, THAT'S ME, WHERE THEY GO?
WHERE IS HE, GET HIM, HE'S
BEHIND YOU!
[BEEPING]
- YOU'VE GOT HIM UNDER CONTROL?
THANK YOU.
GET HIM.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THE AWARD --
HAVE YOU GOT IT?
GOOSE?
STOP IT.
ALL RIGHT.
THE AWARD FOR GAMES FOR IMPACT
GOES TO --
[HONKING]
NO NOT GEESE, GREASE!
WONDERFUL, CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU FOR THE MUPPETS.
WE WANT TO SHARE THESE AWARDS
WITH ALL THE TEAM BACK AT HOME,
WE COULD HAVE NEVER IT WITHOUT
THEM.
>> I WANT TO THANK FOR ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO SHARED THEIR
STORIES WITH US, REALLY MOVING
STORIES WHERE THEY WERE PLAYING
"GRIS."
YOU TRIED TO DO THESE KINDS OF
THINGS, THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
WHO PLAYS AND SUPPORTS "GRIS."
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
- THANK YOU TO BUNSEN AND
BEAKER, LIFELONG DREAM TO HAVE
THEM AT THE SHOW.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION SOMETHING
CALLED THE GAME FESTIVAL.
THE VISION FOR THAT IS TO GET
ALL OF YOU AROUND THE WORLD TO
WATCH THE SHOW, WATCH TRAILERS A
CHANCE TO PLAY A BUNCH OF GAMES.
THIS YEAR WE ARE PARTNERING WITH
STEAM, WE HAVE FIRST LOOK AT
DEMOS FOR OVER A DOZEN UPCOMING
GAMES PLAYING FOR FREE.
NOT NECESSARILY THESE LOCAL
EVENTS WHERE YOU HAVE TO TRAVEL
SOMEWHERE BUT TO BRING IN GAMES
INTO YOUR HOMES AND AT THE
PLACES YOU WORK AND LIVE.
PLAY ALL OF THOSE GAMES, THE
GAME FESTIVAL CONCLUDES SATURDAY
AND WE ARE GOING TO DO IT ALL
ACROSS THE PLATFORMS, IT'S GOING
TO BE A BIG THING.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO PRESENT SOME
MORE AWARDS AND WE ARE GOING TO
PRESENT THE BEST FAMILY GAME.
THE NOMINEES ARE AT "LUIGI'S
MANSION 3", SUPER MARIO MAKER
TWO, "SUPER SMASH BROS.
ULTIMATE," AND "YOSHI'S CRAFTED
WORLD."
KIND OF LIKE NINTENDO'S CHANCES
IN THIS CATEGORY.
IN THE GAE AWARD GOES TO
"LUIGI'S MANSION 3",
CONGRATULATIONS.
CATEGORY OF BEST SPORTS, RACING
GAME AND THOSE NOMINEES ARE
CRASH TEAM RACING NITRO FUELED,
ANNOUNCED LAST YEAR.
DIRT RALLY 2.0, E FOOTBALL, F1
2019 AND "FIFA 20".
AND THE GAME AWARD GOES TO CRASH
TEAM RACING NITRO FUELED.
AND FOR THE BEST MOBILE GAME,
THE NOMINEES ARE "CALL OF DUTY:
MOBILE," "GRINDSTONE," "SAYONARA
WILD HEARTS," SKY CHILDREN OF
THE LIGHT, AND "WHAT THE GOLF?."
IN THE GAME AWARD GOES TO "CALL
OF DUTY: MOBILE,"
CONGRATULATIONS TO THOSE GUYS.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME THE
COCREATORS, YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
ONLINE THAT THEY'VE JUST
ANNOUNCED THE BRAND-NEW STUDIO
AT THE GAME AWARDS, THEY ARE
GOING TO REVEAL THEIR FIRST
GAME.
WE'VE GOT THIS NEW STUDIO, TELL
ME A LITTLE BIT.
- WE TOOK A LONG BREAK.
- WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THE GAME, THAT IS GOING TO
CHANGE NOW?
>> YOU MENTIONED SOME OF OUR
PAST GAMES, WE HAVE PASSION FOR
INTERESTING WORLDS TO EXPLORE.
THIS NEW GAME BUT THIS TIME WE
HAVE A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
APPROACH.
WE BROUGHT A GLIMPSE TO SHOW YOU
THROUGH A TEASER AND WE ARE VERY
EXCITED.
- ONE OF MY FAVORITE FROM EARS
TO SHOW TONIGHT, YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE THE REAL GAME HERE.
HERE'S A LOOK AT THE FIRST
PROJECT, ENJOY.
- THE WEST, A LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY, A PLACE WHERE YOU
CAN BE A HERO, SCOUNDREL,
ANYTHING IN BETWEEN.
THERE ARE ANCIENT POWERS ATWAR
WITH EACH OTHER, STRANGE
ENTITIES LURKING IN THE DEAD OF
NIGHT WITH THEIR OWN RULES.
WELCOME TO THE WEIRD WEST.
♪ ♪
- COMING OUT HERE CAN BE THE
BEST THING TO EVER HAPPEN TO YOU
IF YOU CAN SURVIVE THAT IS.
- UP NEXT, A BRAND-NEW MMO
ACTION RPG GAME FROM A LEGENDARY
FRANCHISE, CHECK OUT THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT.
♪ ♪
- COMING UP, FIRST LOOK AT A
BRAND-NEW GAME FROM AN EXCITING
NEW STUDIO, NINJA IS HERE TO
HAND OUT THE AWARD FOR BEST
MULTIPLAYER GAME.
STILL TO COME, MORE PREMIERES,
MORE AWARDS, AN EXTENDED PREVIEW
FROM "GHOST OF TSUSHIMA."
AND GREEN DAY PERFORMS LIVE.
"THE GAME AWARDS" WILL BE RIGHT
BACK.
- I'M LOOKING FOR --
- STADIA?
THE NEWEST MOST LOGIC DEFYING,
MIND-BENDING PLATFORM ON EARTH.
FORGET BOXES AND CONSULS, JUST
SCREENS AND ELECTRIC AIR.
AND THIS ELECTRIC AIR IS STADIA.
UNLIKE CONSULS, STADIA DOESN'T
TAKE UP ANY SPACE.
IT MAKES NO NOISE, HAS NO SMELL.
- DON'T WORRY, YOU'LL NEVER FIND
IT.
- YOU CAN PLAY STADIA WITH THIS.
♪ ♪
- STADIA HAS THE GAMES ARE
LOOKING FOR.
- WITH STADIA, YOU CAN GO
VIRTUALLY ANYWHERE, LIVE ANY
WHEN.
PLAY WITH ANY WHO.
STADIA IS GAMING FOR FREE RANGE
HUMANS, IT TRAVELS ACROSS
SCREENS.
NO DOWNLOADS, NO UPDATES, NO
WAITING, STADIA BENDS TIME AND
SPACE TO TAKE YOU STRAIGHT TO
YOUR GAME.
TECHNICALLY THIS IS STADIA.
- THE STREAMING PIPELINE
LEVERAGES DECADES OF GOOGLE
RESEARCH.
- STADIA HAS THE GAMES ARE
LOOKING FOR.
- STADIA IS IMPOSSIBLY
MIND-BENDING COMPANY ARE FREE TO
MOVE FROM SCREEN TO SCREEN, IT'S
NOTHING LIKE YOU'VE EVER PLAYED
GAMES ON BEFORE.
ON THINK THE THINGS YOU THINK
ARE THINGS.
FREE YOUR MIND, THE ONE PLACE
FOR ALL THE WAYS WE PLAY.
- YOU GUYS MAYBE HAVE --
- STADIA?
- WHEN PUB G MOBILE PARTNER TO
HELP SAVE THE AMAZON, WE
CHALLENGED PEOPLE ACROSS THE
GLOBE TO STAND TOGETHER AND
FIGHT TO PROTECT OUR PLANET.
- WE'VE ALREADY LOST 20% OF THE
AMAZON TO FIRES AND
DEFORESTATION.
- THE AMAZON IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING US FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE, THANKS TO PUB G MOBILE
FOR HARNESSING THE POWER OF
GAMING FOR GOOD AND THANKS TO
ALL OF YOU WE ARE STARTING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
- LOCAL PARTNERS ON THE GROUND
CAN HELP PUT OUT THE FIRES AND
THE PLANT THOUSANDS OF NEW TREES
IN THE AMAZON.
THIS ISN'T THE END, IT'S JUST
THE BEGINNING.
- THE NEXT GENERATION IS
DEPENDING ON US.
- GO TO GLOBAL GREEN.ORG AND
DONATE TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT.
- FIGHT FOR THE AMAZON.
- NINTENDO SWITCH HAS FLIGHTS TO
WIN AND DISCOURSE TO SETTLE.
FIND YOUR BATTLE, NINTENDO
SWITCH AND NINTENDO SWITCH
LIGHT.
- RISE AND SHINE, IT'S MAGIC
TIME.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO WELCOME
THE CHALLENGE.
PLAY "MAGIC THE GATHERING,"
DOWNLOAD FOR FREE.
- WHAT'S UP GUYS, ON MY STREAM I
I'M ABOUT HELPING MY VIEWERS
ACCOMPLISH THEIR GOALS.
IF ONE OF YOUR GOALS IS TO QUIT
VAPING, TRUTH HAS A PROGRAM THAT
CAN HELP.
IT'S FREE, ANONYMOUS, TEXT-BASED
AND IT'S ALREADY HELPING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE QUIT.
YOU CAN QUIT BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DO IT ALONE.
ENJOY "THE GAME AWARDS."
- HERE'S A BRAND-NEW GAME
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM OCULUS
STUDIOS, CHECK IT OUT.
♪ ♪
- HE IS ONE OF THE MOST WATCHED
STREAMERS ALIVE AND WINNER OF
THE GAME AWARD FOR CONTENT
CREATOR OF THE YEAR, PLEASE
WELCOME NINJA.
- HELLO EVERYONE, THANK YOU GUYS
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
I'VE BEEN PLAYING VIDEO GAMES MY
ENTIRE LIFE AND THERE'S
SOMETHING MAGICAL ABOUT A SOLO
PLAYER EXPERIENCE AND THE ONLY
WAY TO ENHANCE THAT IS TO PLAY
GAMES WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
I HAVE DEFINED MY ENTIRE CAREER
BY PLAYING ONLINE MULTIPLAYER
GAMES AND HERE ARE THE NOMINEES
FOR THE BEST MULTIPLAYER GAME OF
THE YEAR.
>> BEST MULTIPLAYER GAME.
♪ ♪
- SOME AMAZING GAMES, LET'S BE
REAL.
THE GAME AWARD FOR BEST
MULTIPLAYER GAME GOES TO -- IT'S
A LOT MORE DIFFICULT TO OPEN UP
AND YOU THINK.
"APEX LEGENDS."
♪ ♪
- THE LAST FOUR YEARS HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR RESPONDING.
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN CRAZY FOR US,
FOR THE TEAM THAT STUCK AROUND
AND BELIEVED AND MADE THIS MAGIC
HAPPEN, THANK YOU TO THE FANS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE TEAM
AT RESPONDENT OF SUPER TALENTED
INDIVIDUALS WERE GOING WITH US,
WE MADE OUR FIRST
CHARACTER-BASED GAME AND WE
CHANGED IP'S WHILE WE WERE
SHIPPING A AAA SHOOTER.
THANK YOU, I LOVE YOU GUYS.
- CONGRATULATIONS TO RESPOND,
GREAT TO SEE APEX WINNING THE
BEST MULTIPLAYER GAME.
FOR THE PAST FEW WEEKS, FANS
HAVE BEEN CELEBRATING GAMING ON
TIKTOK WITH OVER 450 MILLION
VIDEO VIEWS SO FAR.
JOIN THE CELEBRATION OF DATING
AND ESPORTS VEGAS NIGHT AND
SHE'S A 64, HE'S THE GUY WHO WON
IT RIGHT THERE.
WE GOT SO MUCH MORE GAME AWARDS
COMING UP, THE GAMING ON TIKTOK
CONTEST WILL CONTINUE FOR THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
THE POLL IS OPEN FOR BEST ONLINE
GAME, LET'S TALK ABOUT A BIG
PLAYSTATION FOR TITLE THAT'S
COMING FROM NEXT YEAR FROM THE
GUYS AT SUCKER PUNCH, "GHOSTS OF
TSUSHIMA."
I AM SO EXCITED FOR THIS GAME
AND WHAT SUCKER PUNCH IS
BRINGING TO LIFE.
WE HAVE OUR LONGEST WORLD
PREMIERE ON THE SHOW TONIGHT, A
TRUE CINEMATIC LOOK, ENJOY.
♪ ♪
>> SAMURAI!
[SCREAMING]
♪ ♪
- THE GHOST.
SOME SAY HE DIED ON THE BEACH.
OTHERS SAY HE IS A STORM MADE
FLESH.
WHEN THE WIND THRASHES AT OUR
TENTS, THEY KNOW HE IS COMING.
♪ ♪
- TELL HIM I'M COMING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
[SCREAMING]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- PLAYSTATION.
- THE GAME AWARDS ORCHESTRA,
LET'S GIVE IT UP FOR THE
INCREDIBLE CONDUCTOR TONIGHT.
THEY WILL BE BACK LATER FOR AN
INCREDIBLE MONTAGE CELEBRATING
OUR GAME OF THE YEAR NOMINEES
AND A GAME OF THE YEAR WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SOME VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS, STAY TUNED FOR THAT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER WORLD
PREMIERE, A LOOK AT "GEARS
TACTICS," CHECK IT OUT.
- THEY CAME FOR US, INVADED
EVERY PART OF OUR WORLD.
SO WE DID THE ONLY THING WE
COULD, WE SET THE WORLD ON FIRE.
NOW MY WAR BEGINS BECAUSE THE
MONSTER THAT CREATED THESE
MONSTERS --
- CRUSH THEM!
- IT'S TIME TO GO HUNTING.
- DON'T GO GENTLY.
- BRING IT!
>> COME SEE MY NEWEST CREATION!
♪ ♪
- JUST LIKE WE PLANNED IT.
- LET'S TURN BACK TO TWITCH, WE
ASKED TWITCH TO PREDICT THE
WINNER FOR THE BEST ONLINE GAME
CATEGORY AND THEY CHOSE "FINAL
FANTASY XIV," WE WILL FIND OUT
WHEN WE PRESENT THAT WARD JUST
TWO WINS.
WE'VE GOT MORE GAME
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO GO ON THE WAY,
A PERFORMANCE THAT'S GOING TO
ROCK THE HOUSE BY GREEN DAY, THE
AWARD FOR BEST GAME DIRECTION
AND OF COURSE GAME OF THE YEAR.
HERE'S A WORLD PREMIERE OF A
BRAND-NEW GAME FROM A TEAM IN
CHINA, AND MULTIPLAYER MELEE
COMBAT GAME YOU ARE SEEING FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
HERE IS WAVE POINT.
♪ ♪
- WELCOME TO MAGIC SCHOOL.
NOW THAT WE'VE COVERED FLYING,
LET'S TALK ABOUT GIANT ANGELS,
NOT TO BE CONFUSED WITH BIRD
PEOPLE.
BIRD PEOPLE ARE THEIR OWN THING.
PLAY "MAGIC THE GATHERING,"
DOWNLOAD FOR FREE.
- HOW MANY YEARS HAVE I WAITED
FOR THIS MOMENT?
FOR THE ONE THAT STOOD ALONE
AGAINST THE STORM.
FOR THE ONE THEY CALLED THE
WARRIOR OF LIGHT.
THIS TRAGEDY, GREATER THAN THE
SEVENTH CALAMITY MUST BE UNDONE.
HISTORY MUST BE UNWRITTEN, LET
IT BE RETURNED.
BECOME WHAT YOU MUST, BECOME THE
WARRIOR OF DARKNESS.
♪ ♪
- MY NAME IS LUCA AND I'M 11
YEARS OLD.
MY GAME IS MADE WITH THE
ROADBLOCKS STUDIO GAME ENGINE,
THIS GUY, HE SAYS HE'S DEPRESSED
AS HE PLAYS THE OBSTACLE COURSE,
HE LEARNS ABOUT THE DEPRESSION
BUT THIS IS TO GET PEOPLE
TALKING SO THEY DON'T BOTTLED
HER FEELINGS UP.
- I WAS PREGNANT WITH OUR
YOUNGEST SON AND MY LATE HUSBAND
GOT VERY SICK.
THE DOCTORS CALLED IT A MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODE, HIS MENTAL
ILLNESS OVER TOOK HIM BY WAY OF
SUICIDE AND WE LOST HIM WHEN
LUKE WAS TWO YEARS OLD AT THE
TIME.
- IT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN HOW MY
DAD DIED WHEN I WAS VERY YOUNG.
I WANTED TO SPREAD A POSITIVE
MESSAGE THAT IT'S OKAY TO TALK
ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS.
I HOPE I'VE HELPED PEOPLE.
- NOW, SHE'S A HOST AND PRODUCER
FOR IGN, PLEASE WELCOME SYDNEE
GOODMAN.
- I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE AWARD
FOR BEST ONGOING GAME,
RECOGNIZING THAT WE KEEP PLAYING
OUR FAVORITE GAMES YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE TEAMS
THAT KEEP THESE MASSIVELY
POPULAR FRANCHISES, MORE
EXPERIENCES AND EVOLVING WAYS TO
PLAY.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
- BEST ONGOING GAME.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- AND OF THE GAME AWARD FOR BEST
ONGOING GAME GOES TO "FORTNITE."
♪ ♪
- THIS IS AMAZING, THANK YOU.
LIKE LAST YEAR, WE REPRESENT THE
TINIEST PORTION OF THE NOW OVER
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WORK TO MAKE
"FORTNITE" SOMETHING THAT IS
INCREDIBLE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE ARE SO HUMBLED CONSTANTLY TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN
MAKE SOMETHING LIKE "FORTNITE,"
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
AS I WAS SAYING EARLIER, THE
IDEA THAT WE NEED TO LEAN INTO
WHAT A PERSISTENT VIRTUAL PLACE
CAN BE AND THE MORE WE ARE
TRYING TO EXPERIMENT WITH STUFF,
TRY DIFFERENT THINGS, WE ARE
FINDING MORE AND MORE THAT OUR
GOAL IS TO TRY TO CREATE A
META-VERSE, CREATE A PLACE WHERE
ALL IP CAN LIVE TOGETHER, ALL
KINDS OF EXPERIENCES CAN HAPPEN.
WHERE WE CAN CREATE A THING THAT
IS TOTALLY NEW, AN EMERGENT TYPE
MEDIA.
WE ARE SO INSPIRED BY EVERYTHING
YOU'RE DOING, I'M BLOWN AWAY
WITH WHAT WE SEE HERE TONIGHT.
IT'S ASTOUNDING INCREDIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK YOU
DO, THANK YOU FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO PLAY FORTNITE WHO COME UP TO
ALL OF US ALL THE TIME AND GIVE
US YOUR INCREDIBLE IDEAS AND
YOUR FEEDBACK AND WE CAN'T WAIT
TO KEEP MAKING MORE.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
TAKE A PERSONAL NOTE TO THANK MY
WIFE, MY DAUGHTER, MY FAMILY, MY
PARTY PEOPLE, WE LOVE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- SEE YOU GUYS SATURDAY.
♪ ♪
- FROM THE DEVELOPERS WHO WORKED
ON MAX PAYNE, QUANTUM BREAK,
ARMOR THREE WORLD OF TANKS, AND
TRIVIAL PURSUIT MOBILE?
♪ ♪
[TGUNFIRE]
- WHAT THE FUCK?
- THE COMPETITION IS SENDING
THEIR TEAM.
- AS EXPECTED, LET'S GET THIS
JOB DONE.
>> THAT'S NINE TO FIVE, I'M HERE
WITH CEO MATTIAS, WHAT IS NINE
TO FIVE?
- A NEW FIRST-PERSON TACTICAL
SHOOTER SET IN A WORLD WHERE
CORPORATIONS WILL EVERYTHING AND
BEING A MERCENARY IS ANOTHER
JOB, A LOT OF MODERN SHOOTERS
CAN BE CHAOTIC AND THAT IS WHAT
MAKES NINE TO FIVE SPECIAL.
WE PUT A LOT OF FOCUS ON
STRATEGIC GAMEPLAY, OF THE TEAM
AND PLAYING TOGETHER AND MAKING
YOUR CHANGES AND THE TACTICS
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THAT TRIUMPHS
OVER BRUTE FORCE AT THE END.
- WHEN CAN WE EXPECT TO HEAR
MORE NEXT YEAR?
- WE ARE LAUNCHING THE ALPHA,
YOU CAN SIGN UP AT NINE TO FIVE,
GO AHEAD, ENJOY AND DOWNLOAD.
>> A LITTLE BIT OF A TEASE, WE
ARE GOING TO HAND OUT MORE
AWARDS RIGHT NOW IN THE CATEGORY
OF ESPORTS GAME OF THE YEAR.
THE NOMINEES ARE COUNTERSTRIKE
GLOBAL OFFENSIVE, DEVOTED TO,
"FORTNITE," "LEAGUE OF LEGENDS,D
OVERWATCH.
THE GAME AWARD GOES TO
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS,"
CONGRATULATIONS TO RIOTS.
FOR THE BEST OF E.R.-AR GAME,
THOSE NOMINEES ARE
"ASGARD'S WRATH," "BLOOD &
TRUTH," "BEAT SABER," NO MAN'S
SKY, AND "TROVER SAVES THE
UNIVERSE."
IN THE GAME AWARD GOES TO
"BEAT SABER," CONGRATULATIONS.
FOR THE AWARD FOR BEST
PERFORMANCE AWARDED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR VOICE-OVER ACTING
MOTION AND/OR PERFORMANCE
CAPTURE, THE NOMINEES ARE ASHLY
BURCH FOR "THE OUTER WORLDS"
WORLDS.
COURTNEY HOPE FOR CONTROL.
LAURA BAILEY FOR "GEARS 5".
MADS MIKKELS FOR
"DEATH STRANDING," MATTHEW
PORRETTA FOR CONTROL, AND NORMAN
REEDUS FOR "DEATH STRANDING."
AND THE GAME AWARD GOES TO MADSS
MIKKELSEN.
THE WINNER OF THE FAN VOTE IS A
"FIRE EMBLEM: THREE HOUSES."
FOR, WE ARE SO HONORED TO HAVE
OUR GLOBAL CITIZENS WITH US
TONIGHT, PLEASE JOIN ME AND
RECOGNIZING THIS YEAR'S CLASS OF
GLOBAL GAMING CITIZENS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE ARE SO PROUD OF THAT PROGRAM,
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE THAT YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
I LOVE TELLING ALL OF THESE
STORIES OF AMAZING PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD WHO REPRESENT GAMING
AT ITS BEST.
WE HAVE MUSIC FROM GREEN DAY,
REGGIE IS IN THE HOUSE TO
PRESENT OUR INDIE GAME AWARD,
MORE GAME AWARDS ORCHESTRA AND
THE GAME OF THE YEAR AWARD
PRESENTED BY SOME SPECIAL
GUESTS.
NOW THEY POPULAR ACTION MMO
ACTION RPG BLACK DESERT IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR PC AND CONSOLE BUT
THE MOBILE VERSION IS AVAILABLE
FOR iOS AND ANDROID, GET A
TRUE MMO RPG AT YOUR FINGERTIPS.
♪ ♪
- YOU CAN'T KEEP RUNNING
FOREVER.
- YOU ARE A MONSTER.
>> YOU HAVE YET TO SEE JUSTICE.
♪ ♪
- BE SURE TO STAY IN THE LIGHT.
- LET'S SAY YOU'RE NOT THE SUPER
COMPETITIVE TYPE AND YOU'RE MORE
ABOUT THAT EYE CANDY, THE
SAMSUNG QLED HAS GOT YOU COVERED
THERE TOO.
HDR IS WHERE IT'S AT, QUANTUM
TECHNOLOGY DELIVERS AMAZING
COLOR FIDELITY WHILE DIMMING
ALLOWS THE BRIGHTEST AND DARKEST
PARTS OF THE SCENE TO LOOK THEIR
BEST.
SEEMS LIKE THESE ARE WHY SAMSUNG
QLED WAS AN HONOREE FOR BEST
GAMING TV OF 2019 AND THEY ARE
NOMINATED AGAIN FOR 2020, KEEP A
LOOKOUT.
♪ ♪
- I DIDN'T THINK ANYBODY WAS
REALLY GOING TO PLAY THIS GAME.
WE HAD OVER HALF A MILLION
LETTERS WRITTEN IN A COUPLE
MONTHS, WE ARE NOT PREPARED FOR
IT.
KIND WORDS IS AGAIN ABOUT
WRITING NICE LETTERS TO PEOPLE,
ANONYMOUSLY ONLINE, SHARING
THEIR WORRIES AND MAKING EACH
OTHER FEEL BETTER.
PUSHING THE DEFINITION OF GAMES
IS SOMETHING I GET REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT.
♪ ♪
- FINE TUNED FOR PERFORMANCE,
PURPOSE BUILT FOR PLAYING
WITHOUT LIMITS.
IF STORAGE SOLUTIONS WITH THE
CAPACITY, THE SPEED, AND
RELIABILITY TO WIN.
DRIVE YOUR GAME.
- WE ARE EXCITED TO WELCOME WT
BLACK TO THE GAME AWARDS, THE
OFFICIAL SPONSOR, ALL OF
TONIGHT'S WORLD PREMIERES HAVE
BEEN SAFELY STORED -- GET
COMMAND PERFORMANCE, CHECK OUT
WT BLACK.COM.
NOW I'M VERY EXCITED TO
INTRODUCE OUR NEXT PERFORMANCE,
ONE OF MY PASSIONS OUTSIDE
GAMING IS LIVE MUSIC HERE AND
I'M ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT WHO
WOULD BE PERFECT FOR THE GAME
AWARDS AND THIS BAND HAS BEEN ON
MY LIST SINCE THE BEGINNING.
THEY'VE SOLD OVER 85 MILLION
ALBUMS WORLDWIDE AND THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN VIDEO GAME
ANNOUNCEMENT -- GET ON YOUR
FEET, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THIS
IS GREEN DAY!
♪ ♪
♪ I WANT TO TAKE YOU THROUGH A
WASTELAND I LIKE TO CALL MY
HOME ♪
♪ WELCOME TO PARADISE ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- GET YOUR FUCKING HANDS UP IN
THE AIR!
♪ ♪
♪ DEAR MOTHER CAN YOU HEAR ME
WHINING ♪
♪ IT MAKES ME WONDER WHY I'M
STILL HERE ♪
♪ FOR SOME STRANGE REASON IT'S
NOW ♪
♪ FEELING LIKE MY HOME ♪
♪ AND I'M NEVER GOING TO GO ♪
♪ PAY ATTENTION TO THE CRACKED
STREETS ♪
♪ AND THE BROKEN HOMES ♪
♪ SOME CALL IT SLUMS ♪
♪ SOME CALL IT NICE ♪
♪ I WANT TO TAKE YOU THROUGH A
WASTELAND I LIKE TO CALL MY
HOME ♪
♪ WELCOME TO PARADISE ♪
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- YOU CAN COME DOWN HERE AND
DANCE IF YOU WANT TO, IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FREE, FREE LOVE,
COME ON OUT.
I DARE YOU.
♪ ♪
♪ I GOT PARANOIA BABY ♪
♪ AND IT'S SO HYSTERICAL ♪
♪ CRACKING UP UNDER THE
PRESSURE ♪
♪ LOOKING FOR A MIRACLE ♪
♪ COME ON HONEY ♪
♪ LYING IN A BED OF BLOOD AND
MONEY ♪
♪ WHAT'S SO FUNNY ♪
♪ WE ARE RIVALS IN THE RIOT
INSIDE US ♪
♪ I'M IMPRESSED WITH THE
PRESENCE OF NONE ♪
♪ I'M POSSESSED BY THE HEAT OF
THE SUN ♪
♪ HURRY UP BECAUSE I'M MAKING A
FUSS ♪
♪ FINGERS UP BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ONE TO TRUST ♪
♪ COME ON HONEY ♪
♪ COUNT YOUR MONEY ♪
♪ WHAT'S SO FUNNY ♪
♪ THERE'S A RIOT LIVING INSIDE
OF US ♪
♪ I GOT PARANOIA BABY ♪
♪ AND IT'S SO HYSTERICAL ♪
♪ CRACKING UP UNDER THE
PRESSURE ♪
♪ THING FOR A MIRACLE ♪
♪ COME ON HONEY ♪
♪ LYING IN A BED OF BLOOD AND
MONEY ♪
♪ WHAT'S SO FUNNY ♪
♪ WE ARE RIVALS IN THE RIOT
INSIDE US ♪
♪  ♪
- GET YOUR MOTHER FUCKING HANDS
UP IN THE AIR!
♪ COME ON HONEY ♪
♪ LYING IN A BED OF BLOOD AND
MONEY ♪
♪ WHAT'S SO FUNNY ♪
♪ WE ARE RIVALS IN THE RIOT
INSIDE US ♪
♪ COME ON HONEY ♪
♪ LYING IN A BED OF BLOOD AND
MONEY ♪
♪ WHAT'S SO FUNNY ♪
♪ WE ARE RIVALS IN THE RIOT
INSIDE US ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- HOW ABOUT THAT?
GREEN DAY EVERYBODY,
"BEAT SABER" AND GREEN DAY, THE
COLLAPSE WE ALWAYS WANTED AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT LONG, THE
MUSIC PACK DROPS TONIGHT ON ALL
PLATFORMS, SOON YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO PLAY SIX OF THE FANS ICONIC
HITS AND BRAND-NEW SINGLES FROM
THE ALBUM "FATHER OF ALL,"
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PLAYING
THE GAME AWARDS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SHOW COMING UP,
THE AWARD FOR BEST GAME
DIRECTION, GAME OF THE YEAR AND
WE HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
SURPRISES FOR YOU GUYS, ON
GAMING'S BIGGEST NIGHT.
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER WORLD PREMIERE
FOR YOU TO CHECK OUT RIGHT NOW,
ENJOY.
♪ ♪
- IT IS AN ETERNAL ISLAND OF
LEGEND, A PLACE OF UNIMAGINABLE
BEAUTY AND A GROWING EVIL.
WHERE THE FORCES OF DEATH AND
LIFE ARE IN CONSTANT CONFLICT.
FOR CENTURIES MANY HAVE COME IN
SEARCH OF ITS POWER.
♪ ♪
ONLY TO FALL TO ITS CORRUPTION.
♪
♪ ♪
>> NOW YOU HAVE COME TO THIS
PLACE, LURED BY THE PROMISE OF
POWER AND IMMORTALITY.
THE DARKNESS WILL CLAIM YOU.
♪ ♪
- I WAS JUST DOWN AT IRVINE, I
HAD A GREAT TIME PLAYING IT AND
IT LOOKS COOL, YOU CAN GET MORE
INFO AT NEW WORLD.COM.
PLEASE WELCOME TO THE STAGE, A
GOOD FRIEND OF THE GAME AWARDS,
HE'S BEEN HERE EVERY YEAR WITH A
PERFECT ATTENDANCE RECORD.
HE IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
NINTENDO OF AMERICA, A FRIEND TO
ALL OF US.
YOU CAN FO FOLLOW HIM ON TWITTE,
GIVE IT UP FOR REGGIE FILS-AIME!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> FILS-AMEK IS IN THE HOUSE!
IT WAS JUST OVER 16 YEARS AGO
THAT I JOINED THIS INDUSTRY AS
AN EXECUTIVE.
TRUTH BE TOLD, I'VE BEEN AROUND
AS A FAN AND AS A PLAYER FOR SO
MUCH LONGER.
LIKE YOU, I'VE WITNESSED THE
GROWTH OF OUR FAVORIE FORM OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND NOW
VIDEO GAMES ARE BIGGER BIGGER
THAN THE MOVIE INDUSTRY, BIGGER
THAN MUSIC, BIGGER THAN
TELEVISION.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
VIDEO GAMES CONTINUE TO
INNOVATE.
NOT ONLY IS ENTERTAINMENT BUT
ALSO INTO AREAS FAR MORE
PROFOUND.
EXPERIENCES WITH THEIR
FOUNDATION IN VIDEO GAME
TECHNOLOGY ARE BEING USED TO
HELP SURGEONS PRACTICE BEFORE A
DIFFICULT PROCEDURE.
AND TO ENABLE COLLEGE STUDENTS
TO SIMULATE BUSINESS SITUATIONS
AND DEVELOP REAL-WORLD SKILLS.
I MAY NO LONGER BE AN EXECUTIVE
IN THIS INDUSTRY BUT I'LL ALWAYS
BE AN AMBASSADOR FOR VIDEO GAMES
AS A FORCE FOR GOOD AND A FORCE
FOR FUN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
IN THIS CATEGORY, FRESH INDIE
GAME, YOU CAN SEE HOW GAMES ARE
CONTINUING TO EVOLVE AS
ENTERTAINMENT.
I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT AWARD OF THE NIGHT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE INDIE
DEVELOPERS ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT CREATORS IN THIS
INDUSTRY.
WHY?
BECAUSE EVERY NOMINEE THIS YEAR
AND EVERY YEAR AT ONE TIME WAS
AN INDIE DEVELOPER.
IN THE SAME SENSE THAT EVERYONE
WAS ONCE A KID SKETCHING A
SUPERHERO IN THE MIDDLE OF CLASS
OR LYING IN BED AT NIGHT
THINKING OF WORLDS AND
CHALLENGES THAT NO ONE HAD EVER
DREAMED OF BEFORE.
FOR MY FRIEND, SIGURO MIYAMOTO,
THOSE BEGAN IN THE WOODS AROUND
HIS HOUSE AND FOR MY DEAR
DEPARTED FRIEND SATRUO IWATA,
THEY LED HIM TO DEVELOP HIS
FIRST VIDEO GAME ON A PORTABLE
CALCULATOR WHEN HE WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY BOTH BECAME FIXTURES IN THE
HISTORY OF VIDEO GAMES BUT
FIRST, THEY WERE DREAMERS.
AND THEY BEGAN WITH THEIR
IMAGINATION.
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE AT THE START,
THEY WERE TRUE INDIE DEVELOPERS.
ANY AWARDS EVENT IS BY
DEFINITION A LOOK BACKWARDS.
WHO HAS DONE SOMETHING GREAT IN
THE PRECEDING YEAR?
IN THIS CATEGORY, YOU CAN LOOK
FORWARD.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE THE INCUBATOR
WHERE YOU CAN SEE GREATNESS IS
EVOLVING, IT RESIDES RIGHT HERE
IN THIS CATEGORY RECOGNIZING
BRAND-NEW INDEPENDENT STUDIOS
WHO RELEASED THEIR FIRST GAME
THIS YEAR.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
- FRESH INDIE GAME PRESENTED BY
SUBWAY.
♪ ♪
VISIBLE MUSICAL >> AND THE GAMEO
"DISCO ELYSIUM."
- "DISCO ELYSIUM" ALSO WINS BEST
INDEPENDENT GAME.
TONIGHT THEY ARE TAKING HOME A
TOTAL OF FOUR GAME AWARDS.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE GREAT PEOPLE THAT CAME
BEFORE US.
FOR PROVIDING US THE POLITICAL
EDUCATION, THANK YOU.
- I'VE BEEN LOOKING BACK MY
WHOLE LIFE, BACK TO MY FAMILY,
MY FRIENDS - THEY SAY YOU CAN'T
CHANGE A PERSON BUT A PERSON CAN
CHANGE WITH TIME.
CHANGE OF MIND, CHANGE OF HEART.
THAT MIGHT BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR
YOU.
BUT I CAN CHANGE ANYTHING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- SURPRISE, THERE'S A SECOND
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" ANNOUNCEMENT
TONIGHT, WHY DON'T YOU TELL US
ABOUT WHAT WE JUST SAW.
- THAT WAS QUITE AN EXPERIENCE.
IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING TIME
KEEPING THIS SECRET BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH RIOT FORGED MAKING
CONVERGENCE AND
"LEAGUE OF LEGENDS" STORY.
IT'S A SINGLE PLAYER PLATFORM OR
WHERE YOU PLAY ECHO, A YOUNG
INVENTOR THAT CAN CREATE A
DEVICE THAT MANIPULATES TIME.
WE WILL DELIVER A RICH STORY
EXPERIENCE ABOUT THE PERILS AND
CONSEQUENCES OF MESSING WITH
TIME.
EVEN IF YOU MESS WITH IT A
LITTLE BIT, YOU CAN MESS THINGS
UP.
- HUGE CONSEQUENCES.
- GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE, GREAT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THE NOMINEES FOR A GAME OF THE
YEAR ARE GOING TO GO
HEAD-TO-HEAD IN THE BEST GAME
DIRECTION CATEGORY, WE'VE STILL
GOT SURPRISES LEFT.
THE GAME AWARDS WILL BE RIGHT
BACK.
- DON'T KNOW WHAT TO PUT ON YOUR
WISH LIST THIS HOLIDAY?
IS A WHOLE NEW WAY, ASK FOR A
WAY TO PLAY YOUR FAVORITE GAMES
FROM SCREEN TO SCREEN.
- ITS STADIA.
- STADIA GIVES YOU MAGIC ZAPPING
SO YOU CAN TURN SCREENS INTO
GAMING MACHINES.
IT'S A GIFT THAT WON'T EVER STOP
GROWING.
IT'S A GIFT THAT DOESN'T TAKE UP
ANY SPACE.
A GIFT THAT GIVES YOU GAMES
ANYWHERE AND EVERYWHERE WITH
WI-FI.
CAN EVEN ASK YOURSELF FOR STADIA
AND GIVE IT TO YOURSELF.
GET THE UNTHINKABLE NOTE
DOWNLOAD SELF GIFT, ONE PLACE
FOR ALL THE WAYS WE PLAY.
♪ ♪
- NINTENDO SWITCH HAS WORLDS TO
EXPLORE AND ADVENTURES TO
CONQUER.
♪ ♪
FIND YOUR ADVENTURE ON NINTENDO
SWITCH AND NINTENDO SWITCH LITE.
- WE HEARD YOU MAY WANT TO QUIT
VAPING.
- WE CAN'T HELP YOU, WE CAN
BARELY HOLD THESE PROTEST SIGNS.
- WE CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THIS
EASY TEXT TO QUIT THE SURFACE,
IT'S THE LEAST AND MOST WE CAN
DO.
♪ ♪
>♪ ♪
- WHAT'S GOING ON EVERYBODY, I
PROFESSIONAL ESPORTS AND HOST
COMMENTATOR GOLDEN BOY AND SINCE
2017 SAMSUNG AND XBOX HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER TO DELIVER
AMAZING EXPERIENCES FOR ALL
GAMERS, THAT'S WHY I TEAMED UP
WITH THEM TO CREATE SOMETHING
SPECIAL FOR THE FANS.
THE ULTIMATE FT W SWEEPSTAKES
AND I WANT TO GIVE A HUGE SHOUT
OUT TO OUR WINNER, BUDDY ROY.
YOU ARE THE WINNER OF THE
UPGRADE SWEEPSTAKES, 8Q70 SOUND
BAR AND XBOX ONE X AND 12 MONTHS
OF XBOX GAME PASS ULTIMATE.
CONGRATS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US TONIGHT, LET'S
ENJOY "THE GAME AWARDS" SOME
MORE.
- THANK YOU GOLDEN BOY, NOW IT'S
TIME FOR AN ANNOUNCEMENT I THINK
YOU WILL BE EXCITED FOR.
♪ ♪
- THERE WAS A TIME WHEN YOU WERE
HEARTLESS, BRUTAL, A MONSTER.
AND I'M PROUD OF YOU FOR
CHANGING ALL OF THAT.
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO BE THOSE
THINGS ONCE MORE.
FOR THEM.
FOR ME.
CAN I COUNT ON YOU?
- ALWAYS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- NOW, SHE'S AN EMMY-WINNING
WRITER AND AN ACCOMPLISHED VOICE
ACTOR.
PLEASE WELCOME ASHLY BURCH.
♪ ♪
- HELLO EVERYONE.
THE BEST GAMES START WITH A
SINGLE PERSON ASKING A SINGLE
QUESTION.
WHAT IF?
WHEN THAT QUESTION EXCITES OTHER
PEOPLE AND THEY START ASKING
WHAT IF, IT'S A SNOWBALL OF
CREATIVITY AND PASSION THAT
PUSHES GAMES TO BE THE BEST THEY
CAN POSSIBLY BE.
THESE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
GAME DIRECTION.
- BEST GAME DIRECTION.
- YOU CALLED ME AND HERE I AM.
- IT'S SO HARD TO FORM A
CONNECTION.
- YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE UP
AGAINST.
- THE WINNER FOR BEST GAME
DIRECTION GOES TO
"DEATH STRANDING."
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- IT WAS START FROM ZERO FOUR
YEARS AGO BUT I'M VERY HAPPY TO
COME TO THIS STAGE TONIGHT.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- I REALLY WANT TO THANK A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO STARTED THIS SHIP
GOING, SONY STARTED OUT WITH US
AND ALSO GORILLA FOR PROVIDING
THE GAME ENGINE.
IT WAS A SMALL BOAT BUT ALL THE
CATS CAME ON BOARD, THE
MUSICIANS, THE ARTIST, THE
PEOPLE WHO COLLABORATED,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL OF THE STAFF CAME AND WORKED
TOGETHER, I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
THANK THEM AND ALSO MY FAMILY
AND BEST OF ALL, THE FANS WHO
WAITED FOUR YEARS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
♪ ♪
>> WE'VE GOT ONE MORE AWARD 2%
AND A VERY SPECIAL SURPRISE
GUESTS TO DO THE HONORS, OVER ON
TWITTER YOU GUYS VOTED FOR THE
GAMING TWEET OF THE YEAR, WE GOT
THE WINNING TWEET -- CHECK IT
OUT, WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
THE GAME OF THE YEAR.
- THE 2019 GAMING TWEET OF THE
YEAR.
♪ ♪
CATCH IT ALL ON TWITTER.
FOLLOW AT TWITTER GAINING.
GAMING.
♪ ♪
- AGAINST ALL THE EVIL THAT HELL
CAN CONJURE, ALL THE WICKEDNESS
THAT MANKIND CAN PRODUCE, WE
WILL SAY UNTO THEM, ONLY YOU.
♪ ♪
>> SHE'S AN ACTRESS AND
PRODUCER, PLEASE WELCOME
MICHELLE RODRIGUEZ.
- HOW ARE YOU ALL DOING TODAY?
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
THERE'S ONE LAST GAME
ANNOUNCEMENT TO SHARE WITH YOU
TONIGHT AND I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT IT.
ALLOW ME 2% OF THE WORLD
PREMIERE OF OUR LATEST EXPANSION
TO THE FAST AND FURIOUS SA
SAGA.
♪ ♪
- I'M GOING TO SPLIT, IT'S THE
ONLY WAY TO KEEP YOU BOTH SAFE.
- I THINK I KNOW SOMEONE WHO CAN
HELP.
- YOU READY TO RIDE?
♪ ♪
- YOU WANT REVENGE?
WE WANT JUSTICE.
- WE ARE GOING TO JUMP ONTO A
MOVING TRAIN?
- I GOT YOU, GO!
- YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME!
>> WHEN IN DOUBT, DO WHAT I DO.
- I'VE SEEN WHAT YOU DO.
THAT'S WHY I'M KIND OF
TERRIFIED.
♪ ♪
>> DO YOU WANT TO STAY OR TAKE
THIS TO THE NEXT LEVEL?
♪ ♪
- I'M EXCITED FOR THAT ONE.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT'S BEEN 18
YEARS -- FROM A LITTLE ARTICLE
IN A NEWSPAPER TO A MOVIE, TO A
VIDEO GAME, PRETTY COOL.
I'D LIKE TO NOW INTRODUCE A
SURPRISE GUEST AND ALSO ONE OF
MY FRIENDS FOR LIFE, VIN DIESEL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
- DO NOT TEMPT ME!
MICHELLE, WE ARE IN OUR CROWD.
WE HAVE BEEN GAMING FOREVER AND
WE ARE AT AN AWARDS SHOW OF OUR
PEOPLE.
- LITERALLY.
WE USED TO SPEND ALL NIGHT
PLAYING FIGHTER GAMES OR
STREET FIGHTER.
- IT'S AMAZING TO SEE THAT
TRAILER FINALLY.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU A SECRET I
DIDN'T TELL YOU BEFORE.
YESTERDAY I SAW THE FOUR MINUTE
TRAILER TO FAST 9.
- HOW COME YOU DIDN'T SEND IT TO
ME?
- BACK TO YOU GUYS.
I LOVE ALL OF YOU.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
HERE TO PAY TRIBUTE TO ALL OF
THE NOMINEES FOR GAME OF THE
YEAR ONCE AGAIN, THE GAME AWARDS
ORCHESTRA.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- THEY KEEP TELLING ME DON'T
LEAN DOWN -- AS MY DAUGHTER
WOULD SAY, DAD, TAKE OVER YOUR
FEAR.
AND THE GAME OF THE YEAR AWARD
GOES TO...
"SEKIRO."
- TONIGHT, "SEKIRO: SHADOWS DIE
TWICE" ALSO WINS BEST
ACTION-ADVENTURE GAME.
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- HE'S VERY MOVED.
>> "SEKIRO" HAS A LOT OF
DIFFICULT AND COMPLEX ELEMENTS
THAT MADE US UNSURE WHEN IT WAS
ABOUT TO COME OUT AND WE WERE
BOTH SURPRISED AND OVERJOYED AT
THE REACTION THAT WE SAW.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THE JOY
OF RECEIVING THIS AWARD WITH THE
STAFF OF FROM THE SOFTWARE WHO
PULLED OUT ALL THE STOPS TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN AS WELL AS THE TEAM AT
ACTIVISION FOR THEIR ONGOING
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A
HUGE THANK YOU TO OUR PLAYERS.
WE COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT
YOU AND IT WAS A HUGE HONOR TO
MAKE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO MAKE
THE BEST GAMES WE POSSIBLY CAN.
- THAT'S GOING TO DO IT FOR "THE
GAME AWARDS" 2019, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT
DECEMBER TO KEEP CELEBRATING
GAMES.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
♪ ♪